Guten Morgen, Linus.
Guten Morgen, Tim.
Sag mal, möchtest du noch ein bisschen Hund?
Ich hätte lieber noch ein bisschen was von der Katze.
Logbuch Netzpolitik Nummer 501. Wir befinden uns in einem neuen,
wie soll ich sagen, in einer neuen Dimension, in einem neuen Zahlenbereich.
Und ja, mussten uns ein bisschen ausruhen nach den Ereignissen vor ein paar Wochen, wo wir die 500.
Logbuch Netzpolitik Folge gefeiert haben.
Und das war ganz toll.
Das war sehr schön, ja. Ich bin immer noch ganz stolz, wie coole Gäste wir hatten.
Genau. Und während sich halt andere Leute darüber aufregen...
Dass wir Gäste sagen?
Welches Haustier es jetzt sozusagen zum Essen gibt?
Ich habe kein Haustier mehr. Hast du schon alle aufgegessen oder was?
Ja, die werden ja im laufenden Band in Berlin, kannst ja kein Haustier.
Wenn du eine Katze raust, wird sofort gegessen. Das ist,
schade immer. Was für ein Irrsinn, oder? Was für ein Irrsinn.
So eine infame, dumme Scheißlüge. Was soll das denn?
Naja, weiß auch was es soll. Man prägt damit den Diskurs, weil alle regen sich
dann darüber auf und dadurch verbreitet sich die Botschaft.
So funktioniert das halt mit
dem mediengetriebenen Neofaschismus und das funktioniert ja auch ganz gut.
Und jetzt haben die Leute da in Springfield ganz andere Sorgen auf einmal,
weil natürlich wieder irgendwelche Aufgehetzten, Vollidioten anfangen alle Leute
zu bedrohen und das schürt einfach nur die Aufregung.
Und so funktioniert das nun mal in diesem Medienzirkus. Wenn nicht alle so überlegt
und so ruhig daherkommen, wie wir das tun.
In Ruhe hier einfach mal sich hinsetzen, mal in Ruhe so eine Katzenbraten machen
und einfach mal in Ruhe über die Sachen reden auch.
Ja
so ist es nee, also unsere Veranstaltungen, die sind anders.
Keine einzige Katze gegessen worden kann man auf jeden Fall, also ist einfach nicht.
Auch kein Hund keine Katze.
Kein Hund, wir haben keine Katze und keinen Hund gegessen, alle Gerüchte die
das behaupten, sind einfach nicht wahr. Lies.
Geradezu eine vegane Veranstaltung gewesen.
Es ist Fake News.
Ja, lass uns nochmal kurz zurückblicken dann wirklich auf Logbuch-Netzpolitik 500.
Das war ganz toll für uns, weil ganz viele Leute sind da gewesen und haben unseren
Gästen gelauscht und ja, wir haben ja ein großes Brimborium drumherum gemacht,
wen wir denn nun eigentlich einladen würden und haben das dann auch noch während
der Veranstaltung erst dann verraten, als es jeweils losging. ging.
Ja, und wir waren sehr angetan von der Reaktion und ich glaube,
das hat insgesamt alles ganz gut funktioniert.
Man soll sich ja nicht selber loben, aber es war trotzdem zufrieden.
Machen wir in dem Fall ja auch nicht. Also ich denke, unser Beitrag zu der Sendung
war ja wirklich der, im Prinzip nur, dass wir es organisiert haben.
Die Redeanteile hatten andere, oder die großen Redeanteile hatten andere Leute
und die haben das alle drei großartig gemacht.
Mit Esels Albtraum Albtraum, das war natürlich ein lustiger Start,
also die Gesichter, Publikum hat jetzt nicht lange gebraucht,
um zu verstehen, was sie da vor sich haben, aber so der erste Moment,
den wenigsten, oder sagen wir, die Minderheit kannte Esels Albtraum schon,
die hatten natürlich auch ihre Fans da, aber den Moment fand ich dann doch schon sehr, sehr schön.
Das Interview danach war großartig.
Ulrike Franke war sicherlich thematisch nicht das,
womit die Leute gerechnet haben und war dann auch spitze,
diesen Aspekt mal zu beleuchten und vielleicht auch ein paar Ansichten zu vertreten,
die von uns jetzt so nicht in der,
wie soll man das sagen, erstens nicht in der Tiefe und zweitens nicht in dem
Kompetenzgrad behandelt werden.
Und ja, aber den wirklich irrsten Moment fand ich, als du versucht hast,
deinen sorgsam geplanten Text für Anne Broek hervorzulesen.
Und in dem Moment, wo du sagst, Staatsanwaltschaft Köln gibt schon Applaus,
das hat mich wirklich sehr gefreut.
Beeindruckt, weil ich nicht gedacht hätte, also ich habe schon gedacht,
dass man dem Publikum schon noch erklären muss, wer das jetzt genau ist.
Und dass sie schon irgendwie, ohne dass der Name fällt, schon applaudieren.
Das war da muss, da das war schon sehr cool. Sehr,
berührt.
Ja, das hat mich auch total überrascht, muss ich sagen.
Ich weiß gar nicht, warum. Also es hat natürlich auch gezeigt,
von vornherein schon mal, wie viel Unterstützung doch Leute erfahren,
die sich so für die Gesellschaft einbringen.
Auch wenn sie es selbst nicht unbedingt immer so unmittelbar spüren.
Und wir hatten ja auch mit ihr vorher gesprochen und auch ein bisschen darüber geredet,
wer denn da vermutlich das Publikum
so ist und ich glaube wir hatten so gemutmaßt, dass es schon sein kann,
dass sie da ganz wohlgesonnen ist.
Genau, dass es ganz wohlgesonnen ist, aber Standing Ovations hatten wir jetzt
irgendwie nicht auf der Bingo-Karte.
Ah doch, ich schon, ehrlich gesagt. Da habe ich schon mitgerechnet,
dass es am Ende Standing Ovations geben würde.
Ich wollte es ihr jetzt nicht in Aussicht stellen, aber es war,
habe ich schon mitgerechnet, dass das...
Also war auf jeden Fall toll man kann sich nur bei allen bedanken die daran
mitgewirkt haben die uns auch unterstützt haben das war eine runde Sache und
so kann man das wieder machen vielleicht nicht erst in 500 Folgen.
Ich fand es auch sehr schön, die Leute, also neben denjenigen,
die uns hinter den Kulissen und vor den Kulissen und beim Shirt-Ausgabe und
sonst dem geholfen haben und bei vorangegangenen Sendungen, dass wir dieses
Projekt irgendwie so lange treiben konnten,
auch einfach diejenigen, die da waren.
Ja, also die da waren und das Geld dahin gelegt haben, damit wir das machen
konnten und uns da irgendwie vorher netten Austausch und nachher netten Austausch, das war einfach,
da kann man mich sehr dankbar für diese Möglichkeit, die wir da gemeinsam hatten.
Ja, mal schauen. Wir haben auch schon darüber gesprochen, ob wir vielleicht
mal öfter auch ein bisschen auf Tour gehen.
Natürlich jetzt nicht immer mit so einer groß geplanten Show mit Gästen,
aber vielleicht mal unsere Sendung im Normalzustand einfach auch mit Publikum
zu machen. Das ist ein bisschen schwierig mit dem Terminkalender.
Wir würden vielleicht gerne im Herbst nochmal was machen.
Wir müssten aber vor allem mal Locations dafür haben, die überhaupt in Frage kommen.
Wenn ihr so knuffige Locations kennt,
die mit so einer kleinen Bühne ausgestattet sind, mit irgendwie ein,
zwei hundert Plätzen vielleicht, sowas in der Größenordnung,
die für so etwas geeignet wären, dann würden wir uns da mal über Tipps freuen.
Dann erwägen wir das mal und schauen mal, inwiefern wir sowas demnächst mal
in unseren Terminkalender einplanen können.
Wir versprechen mal noch gar nichts, aber die Hauptarbeit dabei ist halt immer
so dieses Location Scouting.
Und wenn man da schon mal so eine Liste hat von Sachen mit, ja da könnte es
passen, das ist so ein bisschen im Einzugsbereich einer größeren Stadt vielleicht,
dann kann man das ja mal erwägen.
Da könnt ihr uns mal eine Mail schreiben, wenn ihr wollt. Ja,
was wir vergessen haben natürlich bei unserer 500.
Sendung, ist auf die entsprechende Fehlermeldung hinzuweisen.
Immerhin gab es die dann nicht. Alle Server liefen.
Ihr erinnert euch, wir hatten ja mal die HTTP-Fehlermeldung mit dem ganzen 400er-Bereich.
Und den haben wir ja jetzt ausgeschöpft. Das war es mit 4xx.
Jetzt geht es weiter. mit 5XX und das müssen wir natürlich erwähnen,
weil sonst kommen ja alle und sagen, warum habt ihr das nicht erwähnt?
Ja, also erklär mal HTTP 500.
Ja, HTTP 500 ist ja eigentlich so the big fuck up.
Also das ist ja sozusagen, wenn du HTTP 500 bekommst auf einer Webseite,
dann weißt du alles ist im Arsch.
Der Internal Server Error, generischer geht's ja eigentlich kaum noch,
ist so Also dieses, ja, die Software auf der anderen Seite hat sich zerlegt
und ist einfach nicht in der Lage, eine nennenswerte Antwort zu geben.
Und genau das soll das eben signalisieren. Mit anderen Worten,
HTTP 500, wenn das kommt, dann wisst ihr schon, es liegt nicht an euch.
Sondern irgendwas ist auf Seiten der Systemadministration, der Softwareentwicklung
oder sonstiger Faktoren, die da noch eine Rolle spielen,
auf der anderen Seite daneben gegangen und deswegen ist es halt so, wie es ist.
Beispiele, der ist auf irgendeine Weise konfiguriert, dass er einfach überhaupt
nicht weiß, was er machen soll.
Kein Arbeitsspeicher mehr. Nee, das ist ein anderer.
Irgendein Fehler, für die es keine Graceful Exceptions gibt.
Oder auch, der darf auf die Datei nicht zugreifen, die du ihm gesagt hast und
kann deswegen zum Beispiel nicht sagen, ob das jetzt ein 404 ist,
weil er weiß, er hat gar keinen Zugriff darauf.
Noch bevor er sagt, das gibt es nicht, stellt er fest, ich darf da gar nicht
hin und ich kann jetzt nicht mehr wahrheitsgemäß antworten, es gibt einen internen
Fehler und oder das Software ist explodiert.
Das kann natürlich auch sein so Programme stürzen ab Dinge passieren Und.
Jetzt haben wir 501.
Jetzt haben wir 501, hat auch einen schönen Namen das ist nämlich Not Implemented,
und das ist eigentlich so,
sagen wir mal die Antwort auf eine bestimmte Frage Also es gibt ja immer so
verschiedene Methoden, mit denen man die Serverseite befragen kann.
Das Einfachste ist halt einfach so, ja gib mal hier diese Webseite.
Das ist ja so 99,999% der Fälle.
Es ist halt einfach genau das, nämlich so ein Get genau oder ein Head,
mit dem man sich erstmal nur so die groben Informationen holt und den Inhalt noch nicht.
Und wenn aber jetzt sozusagen eine Methode geschickt wird,
mit, ja mach mal dies, mach mal das, spring mal im Kreis, es gibt ja noch so
verschiedene andere HTTP-Methoden, die man theoretisch implementieren kann und
wenn es das halt auf der anderen Seite nicht gibt, dann sagt er halt einfach Bäh, kenne ich nicht.
Das habe ich nicht implementiert.
Haben wir nicht. Das ist dann so wie in der DDR im Restaurant.
Haben wir nicht. Gibt es nur freitags.
Get, also ich muss echt sagen, dass ich nicht genau weiß, welche es alle gibt.
Also es gibt Get, es gibt Head, es gibt Post.
Dann gibt es glaube ich noch Put-Requests oder sowas. Aber ich muss auch tatsächlich
sagen, dass ich mich in meinem Wissen der Request-Arten primär auf Get und Post.
Ja, das ist ja auch, sagen wir mal so, das Standard-Web-Gedöns.
Es gibt dann so Erweiterungen wie WebDAV, wo man so HTTP wie ein Filesystem benutzen kann.
Dann gibt es dann halt das Hinzufügen von Ressourcen, das Löschen von Ressourcen,
Umbenennen. Also alles, was man quasi so auf dem Dateisystem machen kann.
Und dann sagen wir dann 501.
Alter.
Haben wir doch nicht mal implementiert. Genau, gehen wir aus der Sonne.
So. Kennen wir nicht, haben wir nicht. Gibt's hier nicht. Haben wir noch nie
gemacht. Fangen wir jetzt nicht mit an.
Ach ja, genau. Dann haben wir das auch erledigt.
Und nachdem wir jetzt die LMP500, also diese, warum der Tim gerade auch schon
fragt, so nach möglichst kleineren Dingen ist,
wenn man so etwas öfter machen will, dann können wir das auf jeden Fall nicht
mit dem Aufwand machen, den wir bei der LMP500 betrieben haben.
Und bei Tim ist ja vor allem jetzt direkt noch die nächste Event.
Genau, jetzt kommt ja die schon schon hier ein paar Mal erwähnte Subscribe auf uns zu.
Es sind jetzt nur noch knapp vier Wochen.
Wann ist sie denn?
Vom 18. bis 20. Oktober in Berlin.
Wo in Berlin?
Im Bildungs- und Kulturzentrum Peter Edel. Das ist ein toller Name,
oder? In Weißensee, schön gelegen am Weißensee.
Am Weißensee?
Am Weißensee, in Weißensee, der Stadtteil Weißensee, am Weißensee,
dem See, der zwar nicht weiß ist, aber so heißt. Der Kleine? Wieso?
Mit dem Strandbad dran.
Ja, genau. Also im Oktober vielleicht dann nicht mehr,
Also ich rechne jetzt nicht mit Strandtemperaturen, aber es lädt auf jeden Fall zum Spaziergang an.
Kann man einen guten Spaziergang machen. Aber das ist ein kleiner See,
also da gehst du relativ schnell drum.
Weil lange brauchst du einen weißen See zu gehen, eine halbe Stunde? Ja, maximal.
Das geht auch schneller, je nachdem. Wenn du joggst, bist du in fünf bis zehn Minuten drum herum.
So ist es. Aber es geht ja nicht so sehr um den See, es geht ja mehr um die Veranstaltung.
Ja, was soll die denn?
Die richtet sich ja, wie ich schon gesagt habe, vor allem an Podcaster,
aber auch an alle, die ein technisches Interesse haben an diesem Genre,
die in irgendeiner Form dabei kontributieren.
Leute, die vielleicht auch darüber nachdenken, mal selber so einen Podcast zu
machen oder sich generell einfach interessieren für die Produktion davon und
auch für die Community, weil da sind dann sehr viele Podcaster.
Was ich aber immer gemerkt habe bei der Subscribe, was ich wirklich sehr angenehm
finde, ist, da dauert es wirklich nicht lange, bis die Leute miteinander ins Gespräch kommen.
Weil dann einfach… Kann alle ganz gut reden. Ja, es ist ja… Und kennen eventuell
auch die Podcasts der anderen, ne?
Das kommt noch dazu, aber es ist vor allem dieses mit Sprache kommunizieren wollen.
Das ist ja glaube ich schon so eine Voraussetzung auch, dass man in diesem Genre
überhaupt unterwegs sein möchte und von daher war das eigentlich immer sehr
schön zu sehen. Also du wirfst sie irgendwie auf einen Fleck und dann machst
du sofort alles am Brummen.
Das fand ich irgendwie sehr nett und ist einfach cool, so viele interessante
Leute zusammenzubekommen, die einfach irgendwie was mitzuteilen haben und das
tun sie dann halt auch. Jetzt haben wir auch schon.
Worüber tauschen die sich aus? Also du hattest ja glaube ich auch schon mal
erzählt, dass ursprünglich war es der Podlove Podcaster Workshop,
wo dann tatsächlich so wichtige Entscheidungen in diesem ganzen Podlove Webplayer,
Podlove WordPress Plugin, Podlove Software Umfeld gaben.
Diskutiert wurden, also ich erinnere mich einmal, dass dann da,
dann wurde so diskutiert, ja wie baut man, was ist jetzt das Dateiformat für
die Shownotes und wie kann man die auf einem Player anordnen oder wie nicht
und dann so ein bisschen die,
Anforderungen der Podcaster und Podcasterinnen und der Coder,
die sagten, oh Mensch, das kann ich oder da gibt es noch ein Dateiformat,
kannst du so nehmen, das ist schon halb fertig, müssen wir noch aneinander knoten,
solche Gespräche, aber Genau.
Es war ja quasi die Geburtsstunde überhaupt dieser ganzen Szene und auch der Technologie damit.
Und es gab ja eigentlich relativ wenig Technologie, mit der man gut Podcasts
veröffentlichen konnte.
Das war ja quasi die ursprüngliche Intention, Leute zusammenzubringen. Naja, es ist ja viel.
Es gibt zumindest nicht viel.
Es ist viel geschehen seitdem. Und es ist halt auch so ein bisschen eben der
Ort, wo so eine unabhängige, technikunabhängige, also nicht technikunabhängige,
sondern unabhängige Technikszene zusammengekommen ist, um irgendwie ihre Werkzeuge eben selber zu machen.
Aus dem dann auch sehr viel hervorgegangen ist.
Auch teilweise auch kommerzielle Projekte. Und darüber wird es dann halt viel zu hören geben.
Also so die Klassiker ist halt Potlove Und Ultraschall, da wird es dann ausführliche
Talks geben, weil da ja auch jetzt in den letzten Jahren viel passiert ist.
Das wird alles zusammengefasst. Aber es geht auch noch ein bisschen weiter.
Es wird also auch viele Podcaster geben, die so ein bisschen aus ihrer Erlebniswelt
der letzten Jahre berichten werden. Also, wie hat sich so das entwickelt?
Wir haben ja einige Podcasts, die ziemlich erfolgreich geworden sind aus diesem
ganzen Umfeld, die dort hoffentlich alle zur Sprache kommen.
Aber wir haben auch so Beiträge aus dem journalistischen Raum,
also zum Beispiel Riff Reporter, die ja auch teilweise auf Podcasts setzen.
Ich habe auch schon gesehen, dass es so von Heise diverse Besucher gibt,
auch aus dem öffentlich-rechtlichen Bereich kommen Leute. Mal gucken,
ob da noch Vorträge dazu kommen.
Und ja, dann wird es auch noch so ein paar podcastartige Gespräche geben.
Ich werde mich zum Beispiel mit der Maria Buckelberg zusammensetzen,
die ja diese ganzen Zeit-Podcasts machen, ein bisschen über Podcast-Design reden.
Ich will auch noch einen längeren Vortrag machen, mit dem ich mein Old-Fart-Image
aufpolieren möchte und mal eine Technikreise über 50 Jahre Individualkommunikation mache.
Also, wo sozusagen das alles herkommt und wie sich das im Internet so über die Zeit entwickelt hat.
Also wie du früher vor 50 Jahren mit Leuten einzeln reden musstest?
Nee, also...
Ich bin auf diese Welt gekommen, da haben mir teilweise nur drei Leute zugehört.
Ja, also...
Habe ich 50 Jahre gesagt? Nee, ich meine 40 Jahre. Ich fange vor 40 Jahren an.
Also so alt bin ich ja dann auch noch nicht.
Deswegen war ich gerade verwundert.
Nee, aber so, wo es losging mit der Kommunikation.
Modems, Mailboxen, erste Chat-Systeme, Usenet, all diese ganzen Faktoren, Blogosphäre,
Web 2.0, dieser ganze Kram und wie sich daraus eben dann auch so langsam die
Grundlage herausgeschält hat, die dann eben unter anderem auch zu Podcasting geführt hat.
Das VOG wird auch präsent sein, nicht nur weil wir das alles aufnehmen,
sondern auch dort mal diesen Aspekt machen, weil ja auch gerade Live-Veranstaltungen
immer mehr so eine Rolle spielen und auch Video so ein bisschen.
Das heißt, es geht auch so um Konferenz, Recording-Techniken,
was sich da alles so getan hat.
Dann ist halt immer so viel Hardware-Austausch mit dir.
Deins zeige ich mir, meins mit Mikrofon, Kopfhörer ausprobieren,
Mischpulte, all dieser ganze Kram wird zusammengetragen werden und so weiter.
Also es ist, glaube ich, für alle, die da hinkommen, ganz wuselig und ich hoffe, kommt auch alle.
Mhm, also man kann dort über Software reden, die man verwendet,
über die Podcast-Konzepte mit anderen Podcastern und mit den Leuten reden,
die Software schreiben, mit der ihr arbeitet.
Also Ultraschall ist ja schon so, dass das, ja, das wird halt ja von Ralf,
glaube ich, immer noch primär maintained.
Ich glaube, da wirken inzwischen auch noch andere mit, aber ist ja schon noch der.
Ja, das ist eine größere Gruppe. So wie ich bei Potluck so ein bisschen den
Zauberstab immer gewedelt habe mit jetzt lass mal was machen und die Richtung soll es mal gehen.
So hat Ralf das eben dann auch sozial angeregt. Aber das ist natürlich eine
größere Gruppe von Leuten, von denen nicht alle, aber viele da sein werden.
Also man kann auch die Leute mal kennenlernen.
Das ist so das, was Podcast vor allem in Deutschland ganz gut vorangebracht hat.
So, das ist am 18.19. Oktober Ja,
Also für diejenigen, die dann anreisen habe ich manchmal jetzt hier noch ein
Event, was man da noch mitbuchen kann Ja, wenn ich das mal so empfehlen darf Weil am 17.
Oktober, das wäre dann der Donnerstag davor Ja Oder? Ist der Donnerstag davor?
Ja, ist der Donnerstag davor Im SO36 1936.
It's a Match, Hauptsache Punk. Und zwar mit Incredible Herrengedeck.
Und diejenigen, die dir länger zuhören, die kennen auch Incredible Herrengedeck.
Das sind die mit dem FDP-Song.
FDP-Song, ja. Episch.
Episch. Und Esels Albtraum.
Diejenigen, die uns mindestens eine Sendung schon zuhören, kennen auch Esels Albtraum.
Und noch Quenz. Kenne ich nicht. Ist aber bestimmt auch gut.
Das ist Technopunk. Es gibt quasi Chanson Punk von Incredible Herringedeck,
Jodel Punk und dann Technopunk.
Im SO36, jetzt auch kein so unbekannter Ort.
Das lässt sich da ganz gut verbinden, würde ich sagen.
Und dann geht es von Kreuzberg direkt an Weißensee zur Subscribe.
Also das Wochenende, glaube ich, ist ist geklärt.
Wäre jetzt so mein Eindruck.
Hast du die schon mal gehört, Quenz? Hier wird edel Trash zelebriert.
In bunten, ständig wechselnden Kostümen spielt das Duo Live-Musik auf elektronischen Instrumenten.
Eigenkompositionen gehen Hand in Hand mit abenteuerlichen Medleys.
Mozart, Udo Lindenberg, Faceless, Knoch, Fabrik oder Gasehoff.
Nichts ist vor ihnen sicher.
Glühende Bässe mit reißenden Beats und tanzbare Hymnen werden komplett live
vor euren Ohren und Augen erschaffen.
Ziel und Vision des Ganzen, die elektronische Oper für eine bessere Welt.
Also hohe Ziele, ja.
Ja, ja, das muss cool sein. Also wenn die, wenn denen gestattet wird,
wenn denen gestattet wird, zusammen mit Herrengedeck und Esels Albtraum im SO36
zu spielen, dann muss das schon ziemlich cool sein.
Da mache ich mir keine Sorgen, dass das dass das geil wird.
Na gut, dann haben wir das auch noch untergebracht.
Genau.
Kommen wir zu unserem klassischen Programm zurück. Wir begleiten die Apokalypse.
Die Digitalisierung.
Die Techno-Apokalypse. Die gab es jetzt auch im Libanon letzte Woche. Oh Mann ey.
Meine Herren.
Ja, meine Herren, da haben wir glaube ich alle ordentlich mit den Augen gerollt, was ist passiert.
Auf einmal explodierten kleine Geräte, sogenannte Pager,
überall im Libanon und es wurde relativ schnell klar, dass das eine gezielt
geführte Attacke war auf Mitglieder der Hezbollah.
Die Hezbollah ist die vom Iran unterstützte Miliz,
die extrem aufgerüstet im Süden Libanons halt Israel da im Norden ordentlich
Ärger macht seit langer, langer Zeit.
Es gab ja auch schon dort diverse Kriege und im Zuge der aktuellen Auseinandersetzung
mit dem Gaza-Streifen nach den Terroranschlägen im letzten Oktober gab es ja dort auch immer wieder,
also es gibt ja immer Angriffe auf Israel und das ist jetzt halt auch wieder eskaliert.
Also meine Eskalation ist ja sozusagen in dieser Region leider der Normalfall.
Und jetzt passierte halt das, dass eben kleine Pager explodierten.
Muss man vielleicht nochmal erwähnen, was Pager eigentlich sind,
weil es ja eine Technologie ist, die heutzutage nicht mehr von vielen verwendet wird.
Hattest du mal einen? Ich hatte einen Pager.
Ja.
Ich auch.
Natürlich. Und vielleicht kann ich kurz erklären, was Pager sind.
Also man kennt das in, ich würde sagen, wahrscheinlich 80er und 90er Jahre Filmen
spielt das ab und zu eine Rolle.
Du hast also ein kleines Gerät an der Tasche. Das kann im Wesentlichen,
kann das piepen und hat ein Display.
Und die wurden tatsächlich, das ist so irre, ne? Also der Hauptpager konnte
dir Zahlen anzeigen und dann musstest du diese Nummer zurückrufen.
Das war das Kommunikationsangebot eines Pagers.
Also wenn er überhaupt in der Lage war, was anzuzeigen.
Also oft war ein Pager einfach nur piep, piep, piep und du wusstest,
du musstest genau da an der einen Stelle anrufen und dann war dein Einsatz.
Genau, so einen hatte ich als Rettungssanitäter. Das war ein Gerät,
das hat einfach nur gepiept. Da wusstest du in der Regel, okay,
du musst jetzt halt aufwachen und zur Karre.
Und hast einen Auftrag oder eine Fahrt oder was auch immer.
Und dann hast du dir über Funk dann sagen lassen, wo du hinfahren musst.
Wie auch immer, je nachdem, was du jetzt gerade gefahren bist,
ob Notfalleinsätze oder Krankentransporte oder was auch immer.
Aber so der klassische in der Breite verteilte Pager,
der Konsumenten-Pager der konnte der hat dann gepiept und hat dir eine Telefonnummer
angezeigt dann konntest du dich zu einer Telefonzelle begeben oder was auch
immer und dort zurückrufen weil das war halt die Möglichkeit,
war dir eine Telefonnummer zu übermitteln, die du anrufen sollst,
später, so einen hatte ich dann,
Konnten diese Pager auch Textnachrichten anzeigen. Ich hatte einen von Quix.
Kennst du Quix? Das gab es damals. Da musste man anrufen. Also wenn du jemanden
quixen wolltest, musst du eine Telefonnummer anrufen.
Und das hat irgendwie 2 Euro oder 2 Mark oder was gekostet. Oder 1,50 oder weiß der Geier.
Dann war da irgendein Callcenter dran. Dann hast du gesagt, ich möchte an diese Nummer.
Nee, das war eine spezifische Nummer schon. Da war schon eine Durchwahl quasi.
Und dann musstest du einfach nur noch sagen, was du jetzt möchtest.
Und dann hat dieser Pager gepiept und das angezeigt.
Und das System funktionierte tatsächlich dadurch,
dass du mit einer relativ weitreichenden, also niedrigfrequenten,
nicht besonders, also reicht weit,
kann aber wenig Daten, also kann langsam übertragen, aber reicht dafür sehr
weit, Deutschland abgedeckt hattest.
Und die sendeten dann eigentlich diese massenhaften Messages.
Die wurden im Prinzip im gesamten Bundesgebiet ausgestrahlt.
Und dein Pager wusste, auf welche davon er jetzt reagieren muss, weil er eine ID hatte.
Das System ist aber zum Beispiel auch vollständig abhörbar gewesen.
Das war ja auch eine der Wikileaks-Veröffentlichungen, die 9-11-Pager-Nachrichten.
Dass sie da eine Zeit lang offenbar mitgeschnitten wurden, alle Pager-Nachrichten.
Und häufig waren diese Systeme, da geht es jetzt ein bisschen zu sehr ins Detail,
aber die waren auf jeden Fall nicht irgendwie nennenswert wirksam verschlüsselt.
Das war eher, da konntest du halt irgendwie einen nassen Schnürriemen auf dem
Balkon hängen und konntest das mitschneiden.
Das ist halt auch noch so aus dieser Zeit, wo es überhaupt diese Vorstellung,
dass man den Aufwand überhaupt treibt, sowas mitzuschneiden,
da hat man gar nicht gesehen, dass irgendjemand sowas machen würde.
Das heißt einfach nur, dass du so ein Gerät überhaupt brauchst und dass du da
irgendwie die Software manipulierst.
Also das sind so Gedanken, die niemandem nennenswert gekommen sind.
Und es war ja, sagen wir mal, zu der Zeit auch erstmal noch gar kein Problem,
weil wir diese ganzen Angriffsszenarien so in der Form noch gar nicht hatten.
Ich hatte damals auch Du hattest was, hattest du ein Skoll oder wie hießen die?
Ne, ich hatte noch früher City Roof war das City Roof?
Genau, also City Roof war glaube ich auch so von Tim Mobile halt oder Telekom
halt so wann ging das los?
89 war das irgendwie verfügbar genau und da hatte ich so einen kleinen Motorola,
Pager, weil Weil brauchte man ja so als Nerd und ich meine auch,
ich bin mir gar nicht mehr so ganz so sicher, ich meine ich habe das sogar so gehabt,
dass ich halt meinen Anrufbeantworter, sowas hatte man natürlich auch noch,
mein Anrufbeantworter konnte mir halt auf meinem Pager quasi mitteilen,
dass ich einen Anruf bekommen habe.
Das heißt, jemand hat mich auf meiner Telefonnummer angerufen,
hat mir eine Nachricht hinterlassen,
woraufhin mein Anrufbeantworter meine Pager-Nummer anruft und dann hat es halt
gepiept und ich wusste, ah,
ich habe einen Anruf auf meinem Anrufbeantworter, konnte dann meinen Anrufbeantworter
anrufen, dort meine Nummer eingeben, meine Geheimnummer, um dann halt abzuhören und so weiter.
Und das war dann alles super modern, das war so die Realität Anfang der 90er
Jahre noch, weil an Mobilfunk und sowas war nicht zu denken, genau, irre war das.
Jetzt haben diese Dinger eine sehr spezifische Eigenschaft.
Die konnten selber überhaupt nicht senden. Reine Empfänger.
Und das, also eine komplett ungeschützte Kommunikation,
aber ohne großartige Empfangsprobleme, verhältnismäßig, verlässlich.
Klar, wenn du jetzt im Keller warst oder so, kann es auch mal nicht funktionieren,
aber die waren schon auf so einer Frequenz, die wurde jetzt in der Lage,
bis erstmal ganz gut Deutschland abzudecken.
Ähnlich wie Radio, für Radio brauchst du ja auch nicht überall Antennen hinzustellen,
da hast du halt ein paar Antennen in Deutschland, ja klar, aber da kannst du
schon erstmal davon ausgehen, dass das Signal erstmal überall hinkommt.
Im Gegensatz jetzt zu irgendwie so einem 5 Gigahertz Signal,
wo du Schwierigkeiten hast, in den nächsten Raum zu kommen.
Genau, das ist nämlich der Vorteil des dort eingesetzten Frequenzraums,
der so ungefähr bei 400, 500 Megahertz liegt, je nach Anbieter und mit solchen
niedrigen Frequenzen kommst du halt einerseits sehr weit und halt auch andererseits überall durch.
Das heißt so Empfang in Gebäuden, in Kellern, hinter Glas und so weiter,
wo Handys und WLAN-Empfänger ja so ihre liebe Not haben,
das ist halt in dem Frequenzbereich eher unproblematisch und deswegen sind diese
Empfänger halt cool, wenn es eben nur um Read-Only geht und du eben auch,
sagen wir mal, ein Gerät haben willst.
Jetzt kommen wir auch wieder so ein bisschen in den aktuellen Fall rein,
das dich halt auch nicht lokalisiert.
Weil man kann sich natürlich fragen, warum rennt denn Ispolar mit so Ural-Technologie,
die noch nicht mal verschlüsselt ist durch die Gegend,
weil sie Schiss haben und wohl auch aus gutem Grund mit Mobilfunktelefonen leicht
geortet werden zu können vom Feind.
Und nun weiß man, dass Israel ein extrem technologisch
hochgerüstetes Militär hat und natürlich sind sie auch dahinterher wichtige
Personen der Hisbollah Miliz ausfindig zu machen und wenn die natürlich mit
Mobilfunktelefonen durch die Gegend rennen, dann sagen die halt super, schön,
dass du uns deine aktuelle Position immer zufunkst, wir hängen in euren Netzen
drin und lesen das alles mit.
Und das war insofern ein Problem, dass sie dann irgendwann gesagt haben,
es ist einfach alles zu gefährlich, wir können jetzt hier bestenfalls noch mit
Pager durch die Gegend rennen.
Und dann hast du, das kannst du relativ einfach machen, die Dinger kosten heutzutage
sicherlich gar nichts mehr.
Ich war überrascht, dass überhaupt noch welche produziert werden.
Dann kannst du, brauchst halt ein paar Senderanlagen irgendwo,
stellst du auf irgendeinen Hügel so ungefähr und dann hast du relativ gute Abdeckung.
Außerdem kannst du damit natürlich auch Massenkommunikation recht einfach umsetzen
Also statt einer Telegram-Gruppe sendest du dann eben an alle Pager eine Nachricht Und die konnten halt,
kannst du natürlich auch so eine Broadcast-Nachricht senden,
Hatte mein Quix auch, da war dann so Nachrichtenmeldungen Zweimal am Tag kam
irgendwie so, weißt du, so was heute Spiegelall ist Dann stand da,
was weiß ich, was jetzt Besonderes passiert sein soll an dem Tag oder so.
Und genau, weil die Dinger nicht ortbar sind, mildern sie das Risiko,
dass sie als Ziel für eine Drohne oder für eine Bombe oder sonst was dienen.
Dachte die Hisbollah und hat sich deswegen diese Dinger gekauft.
Übrigens auch vermutlich ja, um einfach in dem Fall mehrere tausend Leute koordinieren
und informieren zu können.
Was die Dinger nicht können, ist antworten. Also du musst faszinieren,
weil sie nicht senden können.
Das sind halt reine Empfänger. Also wirklich absurd, dass sowas halt über ein
Jahrzehnt oder so, war das einfach das Ding, dass man so einen Pager hat.
Also Pager sind Wir sind auch heute noch im Einsatz in solchen Bereichen,
wie du schon gesagt hast, also Notdienste,
Rettungsdienste, Katastrophenschutz, weil das ist ja auch, das Thema hatten wir ja hier auch,
als die Warntage dann wieder eingeführt wurden mit Ahrtal, Überschwemmung etc.,
dass da einfach keine richtige Notfallstruktur da war und es auch keine Möglichkeit
gab, das über das Mobilfunknetz zu machen.
Es kann natürlich auch sein, dass die Mobilfunknetze ausfallen und dann ist
es auch gar nicht so eine doofe Idee, eine relativ günstig zu betreibende,
zuverlässige Notruftechnologie noch in der Hinterhand zu haben wie Pager.
Weil alle Mobilfunknetze funktionieren nicht mehr und die sind ja relativ komplex
und dann ist es gut sowas zu haben.
Die einzige andere Technologie, die ähnlich einfach zu betreiben ist und im
Notfall auch noch so ein Rückgriff erlaubt ist, ist UKW vor allem.
Also Radio ist halt auch super einfach und auch nur ein reiner Empfänger,
aber eben nicht mit digitalen Informationen.
So, jetzt geht die Hisbullah hin und sagt, meine Güte, wir haben uns mit Israel
angelegt und entscheidet sich vor gar nicht so langer Zeit, lassen wir lieber auf Pager umsteigen.
Mit den Handys, das wird hier ein bisschen zu heiß.
Korrekt.
Und bestellen sich Pager.
Bestellen Sie sich Pager, irgendwas in der Größenordnung um 5000 Stück und aus
Gründen, die mir noch nicht so ganz klar geworden sind,
erhalten Sie diese zwar von einer taiwanesischen Firma, die die baut,
aber erhalten tun Sie die von einem Händler aus Ungarn.
Und auf diesem Wege finden die den Weg in den Libanon und dort dann in die Hände
der Hispolar-Miliz-Angehörigen, die dann eben damit ausgestattet werden sollen
und liefen dann damit herum.
Man trägt die ja dann irgendwie bei sich, meistens so am Gürtel,
zumindest hat man das früher immer so am Gürtel gemacht.
Aber man muss ja auch mal allen zeigen, dass man sowas hat. So wie mit den Handys
am Anfang, mit diesen durchsichtigen Handytaschen und so.
Und ja, dann ist es nun also passiert, dass die explodiert sind und alle fragen
sich so, wie kann denn das jetzt passieren und vor allem, was ist denn da eigentlich explodiert?
Und manche fragten sich natürlich, kann es jetzt einfach sein,
dass man durch eine Softwareänderung dieser Pager die Batterien in diesen Geräten
so zur Explosion bringen kann?
Nein.
Die Antwort ist nein, genau, weil einerseits
bietet das noch nicht genug Explosionspotenzial und selbst der Fall,
dass man durch Überhitzung oder so die Batterien unter Stress setzen könnte,
also selbst wenn das möglich wäre,
das ist, also wir wissen ja alle, dass so Lithium-Ionen-Batterien schon ein
gewisses Entzündungsrisiko haben.
Die brennen halt sehr, sehr schnell und sehr unangenehm ab, aber die explodieren nicht.
Genau, die explodieren nicht. Heutzutage sind auch die Batterien so designt,
dass die eben so, wie sagt man, solche Stellen haben, die als erstes kaputt gehen,
wo dann eben ein entstehender Überdruck auch gleich abgeleitet wird.
Also das ist es auf gar keinen Fall.
Genau, ist auf gar keinen Fall, zumal auch klar sein dürfte, selbst wenn das ginge,
Die haben da irgendwie, was war das, 2700 so Dinger platzen lassen.
Hättest du ja unterschiedliche Ladezustände dieser Pager gehabt.
Das heißt, bei einigen ist dann vielleicht auch die Batterie alle.
Und wenn die alle ist, dann explodiert die anders, als wenn sie voll ist.
Und das hat sich relativ schnell geklärt.
Und es hat sich eigentlich herausgestellt, was die meisten auch sofort vermuten
konnten, dass es sich um eine Hardware-Manipulation hatte. Die haben die Pager
mit einem Sprengsatz drin, der Hisbollah schon geliefert.
Genau, und diese Modifikation war eh erforderlich, weil selbst wenn es nur die
Batterie wäre, müsste ja dann die Software noch verändert worden sein.
Genau, die Software war auch noch verändert.
Genau, das heißt, das war jetzt eine kombinierte Modifikation.
Dort ist also vermutlich irgendwas in der Größenordnung von zwei Gramm Sprengstoff
eingeführt worden, also so Semtex oder so etwas.
Wenn du da so zwei Gramm Sprengstoff einführst, das explodiert schon ordentlich.
Damit bringst du jetzt kein Haus zum Einsturz, aber darum ging es ja auch nicht.
Zumal ja hier die etwas böse Kalkulation auch lautet, das ist etwas,
was du sowieso an dir trägst.
Beziehungsweise in dem Moment, wo jetzt dort eine Nachricht hingeschickt wird,
das Gerät meldet sich und piepst.
Was machst du dann als erstes? Du nimmst es in die Hand und du schaust drauf.
Und da, man hat auch schon jetzt gehört, es sind ja auch einige Leute dann getötet worden,
viele sind sehr schwer verletzt worden, insbesondere an der Hand und insbesondere
auch an Augen und dementsprechend wird das genau so gelaufen sein,
das heißt da war eine Software drin,
die so quasi wie so eine Schläferzelle nur darauf gewartet hat,
eine bestimmte Nachricht zu empfangen und diese bestimmte Nachricht,
Hat dann eben dieses Szenario getriggert. Das heißt vermutlich hat sie,
weiß ich jetzt nicht genau, aber vermutlich hat sie einfach die normale Benachrichtigung
gemacht und dann mit einer bestimmten zeitlichen Verzögerung die Explosion ausgelöst.
Und das ist ja auch bestätigt durch viele Videos von Überwachungskameras,
wo das irgendwie eingefangen wurde.
Also das ist, das ist so eine krasse Operation.
Also die Vorbereitung, die Vorbereitung dafür.
Du kannst ja nicht, also was ich ausschließen würde ist, dass irgendjemand bei
der Hisbollah sagt, lass mal 5000 Pager kaufen und Israel sagt,
lass mal schnell 5000 manipulieren.
Ich würde eigentlich denken, um sowas hinzukriegen, musst du wirklich echt die
Organisationen durchsetzt haben,
um die erstmal dahin zu kriegen, dass die auf Pager umsteigen und dann zu sagen, nehmt mal unsere.
Also das ist schon, und die Vorbereitung, also du musst ja auch,
also irgendwo haben Menschen gesessen, haben 5000 Pager mit Sprengladungen versehen.
Das ist schon, also das ist eine Operation von einem Ausmaß, das wirklich krass ist.
Absolut und damit war ja dann auch die Geschichte noch gar nicht beendet.
Also erst ging es ja mit den Pagern los, am 17.
September war das und am 18. gab es dann nochmal eine Explosion von Geräten.
In dem Fall waren es aber nicht Pager, sondern, oder es waren wohl auch Pager,
aber auch Walkie Talkies.
Handfunkgeräte, ja. Ja.
Und, ähm...
Also auch das ist quasi eine Technologie, auf die die Hispola umgestiegen ist,
aus denselben genannten Gründen.
Und offensichtlich gab es also auch hier noch ein Batch dieser Walkie Talkies,
die eben auch modifiziert wurden auf eine ähnliche Art und Weise.
Und die auch in irgendeiner Form durch ein Signal von außen aktiviert werden
konnten. Jetzt ist ein Walkie-Talkie ja eigentlich normalerweise,
ich weiß gar nicht, ist das ein rein digitales Gerät?
Glaube ich nicht, aber das ist...
Kommt drauf an, wie alt das ist, ne? Also aber heutzutage würdest du eher so
PMR, DMR, also schon digitale Modulationen haben.
Ja, also da ist auf jeden Fall...
Aber klassische Amateurfunkgeräte haben ja Frequenzmodulationen,
wo ich jetzt, das würde ich nicht als digital bezeichnen.
Ja, ne, aber die haben auch so DTM-FD-Coder drin und so weiter.
Also die Platine da drin ist schon in der Regel, da ist schon irgendwas Digitales mit drin heutzutage.
Genau und wenn man in irgendeiner Form ein diskretes Signal da rein bekommt,
dann kann man eben damit auch Software aktivieren und wenn Software erstmal
aktiviert ist, dann kann sie halt machen was sie will und in dem Fall ja das.
Ja, also es ist auf jeden Fall eine krasse Aktion, dem folgten ja dann auch
noch Angriffe auf Hispolarführer, die sich dann eben im Keller irgendwo alle
zusammen getroffen haben, weil offensichtlich eine andere Kommunikation schwierig war.
Also das Ganze ist schon eine wirklich krass geplante Aktion und wir haben jetzt auch gesehen,
das Ganze war offensichtlich auch nur der Vorlauf zu einer größeren militärischen
Aktion, die jetzt gerade passiert werden wir hier mit euch.
Also Sascha Lobo hat das in seiner Kolumne den Hybriden-Cyber-War genannt.
Wir hatten da ein bisschen drüber gesprochen.
Ich wurde auch in der Kolumne mit einem Zitat zitiert.
Er brauchte ein bisschen, um mich zu überzeugen. Weil er natürlich sagen kann,
im Prinzip ist das ja überhaupt nicht.
Da gab es ja überhaupt gar kein Cyber. Was sie gemacht haben ist,
die haben den Geräte verkauft, die nah an ihren manipulierten Geräten,
mit denen sie in der Lage waren, gezielte Sprengstoffanschläge zu verüben.
So könnte man das jetzt nüchtern betrachten.
Dann kann man aber natürlich hinzufügen, naja, aber das war jetzt halt in deren
Kommunikationssystemen,
die haben also nicht nur diese ganzen Menschen verletzt und einige getötet,
sondern auch der Organisation ihre offenbar wichtigste oder zentrale Kommunikationsmöglichkeit genommen.
Und dann baue mal deine Organisation wieder auf,
wenn du kein verlässliches Kommunikationsnetz mehr hast, kein Massenmedium,
weil das werden diese Pager eher gewesen sein und die Leute Angst haben müssen
vor jedem Gerät, was du denen in die Finger drückst.
Ja, also dass die am nächsten Tag noch diese Walkie Talkies benutzt haben,
ähm, fand ich halt auch heftig, ne, also so, da hätte ich auch nicht mehr mit
gerechnet, aber ja also, die haben den Demo skizziert, wenn ihr,
wenn ihr eine Pager kauft, egal woher,
dann machen wir dann haben wir den gebaut und wir machen dass der in eurer Hand
explodiert, so das ist schon wirklich eine.
Ein Schlag an eine Organisation, die halt wirklich mal überlegen muss,
wie wollen die sich denn da jetzt, wie wollen die sich neu.
Koordinieren und wieder aufbauen? Das ist schon wirklich ein.
Richtig krasse Aktion. Und wenn jetzt, wenn der nächste Hisbollah-Typ kommt
und sagt, pass auf, ich hab hier, jetzt hab ich wirklich was Sicheres,
dem traust du doch nicht, den,
denkst halt auch, ja, pass mal auf, der Letzte, der ankam, der hat meinen Kumpel
hier den Arm gekostet mit seinem Scheiß und jetzt kommst du hier hiermit irgendwie,
was weiß ich, was du da jetzt wieder anschleppst.
Das ist schon richtig, richtig übel. Und da finde ich diese Idee oder diese
Teilrechnung zu tragen,
dass das nicht nur ein Angriff auf die Menschen ist, sondern eben auch auf die
Organisation und auf die Mittel der Kommunikation, die sie braucht,
fand ich auf jeden Fall einen Gedanken, der es wert war, sich zu machen.
Auf jeden Fall eine krasse Maßnahme und das wird die Hispola eine Weile brauchen,
bis sie sich da wieder findet.
Zumal sie jetzt dann auch noch im Angriffsmodus sind, offenbar ein Großteil
ihrer Führungsmitglieder mindestens verletzt ist.
Im besten Fall sind sie nur ihrer
Kommunikation beraubt und im schlimmsten Fall sind sie halt schon tot.
Das war einer der Aspekte, die mich insgesamt nochmal an dieser Sache zunächst
irritiert haben, weil meine These,
also ich rede ja nicht hier in der Sendung, aber in anderen Sendungen oder Vorträgen
häufig über den sogenannten Cyberwar und was ich glaube, was da passiert und
was halt zum Beispiel auch nicht passiert.
Angriffe auf Kommunikationsinfrastrukturen bieten sich ja militärisch eigentlich
genau dann an, in Kombination mit einem Angriff.
Also was wir gesehen haben, Russland hat die Ukraine angegriffen und an dem
Tag diese Kasat-Bodenstationen mit einem kaputten Update versehen,
um dem ukrainischen Militär die Möglichkeiten der Kommunikation zu nehmen.
Also Kommunikation zu zerstören macht vor allem Sinn in Kombination mit einem Angriff.
Und ich war zunächst verwundert, weil, also ehrlich gesagt, ich glaube es wird
auch so die These ventiliert, dass man davon ausgeht, dass die eventuell nicht
geplant hatten, die jetzt gerade in dem Moment hochgehen zu lassen,
sondern dass vielleicht drohte, dass ihnen jemand auf die Schliche kommt oder so.
Also, weil ich glaube, der Zeitpunkt ist auf jeden Fall nach dem,
was man strategisch denken würde, nicht der optimale.
Warum nicht?
Weil ich erwarten würde, dass du das mit einem anderen Angriff zeitgleich machst.
Na, haben sie ja jetzt gemacht.
Ja, aber zeitgleich meine ich wirklich zum gleichen Zeitpunkt.
Und nicht irgendwie, jetzt fliegen dir die Pager um die Ohren und eine Woche
später gibt es noch eine Offensive.
Naja gut, ich meine, sie haben jetzt zwei der ranghöchsten Militärchefs ausgeschaltet im Nachgang.
Genau, im Nachgang.
Ja gut, aber der Nachgang war unter Umständen nur möglich als Reaktion auf diese Pager.
Die mussten sich dann treffen, was sie sonst vielleicht so nicht getan hatten.
Und dann hatten sie auf einmal alle in einem Keller. Und das wüssten sie dann halt auch noch.
Also da stecken wir jetzt so nicht drin, aber mir erscheint das schon alles
extrem genau kalkuliert zu sein. Und ja, also. so.
Also ich würde sagen, wenn man im Hass-Business ist, ne, so und eine Bevölkerungsgruppe
braucht oder ein Land, auf das man Hass schiebt, ja, um irgendwie Menschen aufzuhetzen, um, äh,
da sollte man sich sehr genau überlegen, welche Bevölkerungsgruppe man sich da aussucht.
Am besten lässt man den Scheiß ganz sein, aber, ähm, so ich Israel ist irgendwie ungeeignet.
Das wäre jetzt so meine Einschätzung.
Für was? Als Gegner? Oder?
Ich würde mich, also ich habe auch, also was die jetzt demonstriert haben an,
was sie können mit ihren Geheimdiensten und was für ein Level an Operationen sie machen,
das ist schon, würde ich sagen.
Ja, ja, absolut. Absolut.
Benchmark. Ja gut, ich meine, klar, sie sind auch ein Land, was einfach mal
alle angrenzenden Länder hassen. Das ist irgendwie eine der am meisten gehassten
Bevölkerungsgruppen auf dem ganzen Planeten.
Gründe dafür größtenteils unklar aber unter dem Druck machen die schon wirklich irre Dinge dinge.
Ja also das ist auf jeden
fall der technische hintergrund dabei und die
eigentliche frage die sich ja jetzt stellt ist was hat
das für konsequenzen für die sicherheit von solchen
geräten weil wir merken auch wieder dass also digital gesteuerte geräte die
vernetzt sind auf einmal ganz andere bedrohungsszenarien ermöglichen die man
so vorher noch nie gekannt Das wird schwierig,
sich dagegen zu legen.
Also die haben schon, wenn ich mich nicht täusche, haben die doch schon vor
20 Jahren jemanden mit einem Sprengsatz am Handy irgendwie getötet, oder?
Ja, also 20 Jahre weiß ich jetzt nicht, aber es gab auf jeden Fall im letzten
Jahr eine ähnliche Geschichte im Iran.
Also auch da schien ja Israel dahinter zu stecken, nur Pager hatte jetzt sozusagen
noch keine auf dem Zeiger und die Walkie Talkies glaube ich auch nicht.
Da gehört ja überhaupt noch sehr viel mehr dazu.
Insofern finde ich, ist dieser Begriff Cyberwar an der Stelle auch absolut gerechtfertigt,
weil nur die Geräte alleine bringen es ja nicht.
Du musst ja dann auch noch in der Lage sein, die Signale rauszusenden.
Du musst auch noch in der Lage sein, das zeitlich zu koordinieren.
Du musst ja dann auch die Intelligence daraus bekommen, die du brauchst.
Sind die Dinger verbreitet? Wer hat die jetzt?
Ist jetzt der Zeitpunkt gekommen?
Das Ganze darf dann auch nicht rauskommen, etc. Also, ja.
1996 Hamas Militärchef und Bombenbauer,
Jihia Ayyash dem haben sie auch eine Bombe ins Telefon und da war das Ding,
dass sie also wenn man das Handy angerufen hat war nicht der dran dann haben sie glaube ich,
gesagt, sie müssen mal mit dem sprechen bis der dann am Telefon war und sie
an seiner Stimme erkannt haben, das ist er jetzt dann haben sie den Knopf gedrückt
und dann ist das Telefon geplatzt,
das ist äh Ja, da würde ich mir andere Gegner suchen.
Und ich glaube, genau das hat Israel natürlich auch mit diesen Operationen vor.
Ja, also wirklich Next Level Shit. Man staunt einfach nur.
Und ich musste viel an das Gespräch mit Ulrike Franke zurückdenken,
was wir bei der LMP 500 hatten.
Weil auf Anhieb gibt es eigentlich nur ein Wort, das mir zu dieser Operation
einfällt und das ist teuflisch.
Es ist halt einfach wirklich fucking evil.
Und wenn du...
Aber dann kann man natürlich, was Ulrike ja auch ausgeführt hatte,
zu sagen, so Moment mal, die haben jetzt halt irgendwie, weiß ich nicht wie
viele Hisbollah-Kombatanten und zwar nur die getroffen.
Und jetzt klar, dann kann man noch sagen, dann wird man noch,
also neben der einen oder anderen.
Da wird es noch irgendwo.
Genau, da gibt es dann irgendwie einen Prozentsatz Kollateralschaden.
Aber der wird sich natürlich in einem, also wahrscheinlich gab es noch nie einen
solchen Massenanschlag auf so viele Menschen,
bei dem der Anteil Unbeteiligter oder Unschuldiger so klein war.
Und das war ja etwas, worüber Ulrike viel gesprochen hatte.
Ja, fand ich, ja, also das gibt einem auf jeden Fall zum Nachdenken, die ganze Nummer.
Ich habe meinen Pager übrigens schon lange, vor vielen Jahren auf Ebay verkauft.
Du hast doch mal Glück gehabt.
An so einen Amateurfunker.
Ich weiß nicht, habe ich noch einen? Ich glaube, ich habe neulich mal in irgendeiner
Kiste rumgekramt mit so alter Technik, die ich nicht bereit war wegzuwerfen.
Ich glaube, da lag auch noch so mein alter Motorola City Roof Pager rum.
Muss ich nochmal gucken.
Ebay.lb.
Gut.
Weitere Angriffe gab es auch auf das Tor-Netzwerk.
Ja, das ist eine auch sehr krasse Meldung oder so krass ist sie vielleicht auch
gar nicht. Also ich finde sie eigentlich nicht überraschend.
Und Tor, viele von euch werden es kennen,
ein Anonymisierungsnetzwerk, ich werde es jetzt mal ganz schnell,
ganz high level nochmal kurz zusammenfassen, das primär darüber funktioniert,
dass Traffic mehrfach umgeleitet wird.
Also nehmen wir mal als Beispiel, ihr ruft logbuchnetzpolitik.de auf in eurem
Browser, dann fragt euer...
Dann fragt euer Browser als allererstes den DNS-Server, wo die IP-Adresse ist
und dann wird eine Verbindung zu der IP-Adresse von logbuchnetzpolitik.de gemacht.
Dann kommen die ganzen HTTP-Status-Codes, die wir hier besprechen und dann kommt
die Datei, die ihr haben wollt.
So, wenn man jetzt euren Internetanschluss oder den von unserem Webserver überwachen
würde, könnte man dort jeweils sehen, dass ihr dort zugegriffen habt.
Und Tor ist quasi ein Protokoll, das sagt, wir schalten mehrere Stationen dazwischen, und zwar drei.
Und diese drei Stationen, die dazwischen sind, die haben jeweils einen eigenen
Key, an den wir verschlüsseln und die können jeweils nur die Nachricht,
die an sie geht, entschlüsseln.
Das heißt, in diesem Fall, ich schicke als allererstes mein Request an die Gartnode,
an meinen Eingang in das Tornetz.
Und das, was der auspacken und entschlüsseln kann, da steht einfach nur drin,
nimm dieses Datenpaket bitte und schick es weiter an diesen folgenden Knoten,
der sich irgendwo anders auf diesem Planeten befindet.
Und der Rest ist wiederum verschlüsselt. Jetzt kommt der andere Knoten und sagt,
was ist das denn jetzt hier? Und da steht drin, nimm das bitte und schick das
an diesen Knoten weiter.
Dann schickt er das an den Knoten weiter und der wiederum packt es aus und da
steht dann drin, übrigens, ich hätte gerne einen Request gesendet an logbuchnetzpolitik.de,
mach den mal bitte und dann schick mir das bitte zurück und zwar wieder dreimal verschlüsselt zurück.
Und dadurch wird die Kommunikation etwas langsamer, aber du hast jetzt die Situation,
dass wer deinen Internetanschluss überwacht, nicht sieht, dass du zu Logbuch-Netzpolitik
gehst und wer Logbuch-Netzpolitik überwacht, nicht sieht,
dass es du warst, der diesen Request geschickt hat.
Und logbuchnetzpolitik.de wüsste dann eben auch nur, naja, das kommt über einen
Tor-Exit und das funktioniert enorm gut,
aber hat eine quasi eine Falle, wenn nun es ein Global Adversary gäbe,
der alle drei Knotenpunkte, die du gewählt hast,
und da gibt es ja unendlich viele Kombinationen, die du wählen kannst,
weil es ganz viele Guard Notes, Middle Notes und Exits gibt,
Der das alles sieht, dann könnte er ja korrelieren und sehen,
aha, guck mal hier, dein Anschluss hat genau so etwas geschickt und dann ist
das bei Tim angekommen, dann kam wieder so viel zurück.
Das wäre also quasi eine Korrelation von Traffic.
Und weil man Tor nur selten nutzt, nur so ein bisschen, ist das im Prinzip ja
quasi ausgeschlossen, dass das gelingt, weil man auch wissen müsste,
welche Circuits du aufbaust, also über welchen Guard gehst du rein,
welchen Mittel und dann wechselst du die auch andauernd.
Das heißt jetzt so Traffic-Korrelationsanalysen passiver Natur sind eigentlich
sehr, sehr, sehr schwierig.
Wenn man aber jetzt beispielsweise in der Lage wäre, über einen längeren Zeitraum
Unterbrechungen in diesem Netz zu setzen, die zu Verzögerungen führen,
Dann könnte man quasi dadurch nach und nach ausschließen, was deine Verbindung
ist, die du gerade nutzt.
Das ist aber jetzt relativ egal, weil du die deshalb auch immer die ganze Zeit änderst.
Jetzt ist das Tornetz aber, hat
noch ein weiteres Feature und das sind die sogenannten Hidden Services.
Du kannst also auch sagen, ich möchte in diesem Netzwerk etwas anbieten und
ich möchte als Anbieter anonym sein.
Das heißt, es gibt gar nicht mehr den Exit, es passiert nicht mehr,
dass Dinge überhaupt nochmal aus diesem Netz rauskommen, sondern die Nachricht
wird in diesem Netz zugestellt und sie geht über dieses Netz auch zurück.
Und das machen zum Beispiel, also das würdest du machen, wenn du eine Webseite
hast, wo du nicht möchtest, dass Leute wissen, wo der Server steht.
Nutzen sicherlich auch sehr viele legitime Anbieter, aber Hidden Services sind
schon auch das Mittel der Wahl für so Ransomware-Gangs,
für Foren, die in irgendeiner Weise sich mit illegalen Dingen auseinandersetzen.
Aber du kannst natürlich genauso gut deinen Dissidenten-Blog und so weiter drauf hosten.
Im Prinzip also eine Methode, dass man deinen Server nicht findet.
Und jetzt hast du aber beim Server natürlich das Problem, der ist dauerhaft
erreichbar und jetzt kannst du natürlich hingehen und sagen,
du machst genau solche Korrelationsanalysen, solche Timing-Korrelationen,
schaltest einfach irgendwo bestimmte Verbindungen, störst du und guckst,
ob das einen Effekt hat auf deine Kommunikation mit diesem Server.
Und Hidden Services kannst du aber relativ schnell hochziehen,
brauchst nur so ein Key-Pair für, dann funktioniert dein Hidden Service.
Und das wurde von einer Applikation mit dem Namen Ricochet, also Querschläger
genutzt, die im Prinzip darüber einen Messenger-Dienst gemacht hat.
Und jetzt ist halt, also der das,
die zusätzliche Angriffsfläche ist, also jetzt, du bist auch,
du bist nicht nur, sendest du in dieses Tornetz, wie du es für richtig hältst,
Requests sondern, du antwortest auch auf welche.
Und du bist erreichbar und zum Beispiel, man kann da kurz was hinpingen und
dann kriegt man eine Antwort, ne, man schickt eine Nachricht,
dann kommt die an oder man kann diese Nachricht deliveren, ja Ja,
und wenn du jetzt so eine Situation hast,
dann kannst du natürlich sagen, alles klar, angenommen, du kannst jetzt global
am Netz Unterbrechungen vornehmen,
dann gelingt es dir natürlich, wenn du ein Global Adversary wärst,
zu sagen, alles klar, ich kappe mal für eine Sekunde,
ich mach's jetzt plump, ne, ich kappe jetzt mal für eine Sekunde hier so dieses
Unterseekabel und guck mal, ob ich eine Sekunde Verzögerung habe.
Auf dem Weg zu dir habe, ah, das ist es nicht, gucken wir mal hier.
Wenn du dann außerdem noch einen Teil dieses Tornetzes selber betreibst,
also ein paar Entry Notes, ein paar Middle Notes, ein paar Exit Notes,
dann kannst du irgendwann mit ausreichender Zeit über so ein Ausschlussverfahren
sagen, da ist er nicht, da ist er nicht, da ist er nicht, da ist er nicht,
da ist er nicht und irgendwann,
schaltest du an einer bestimmten Stelle und merkst, jo, ich habe eine Route
gefunden, die da hinführt.
Und wenn die jetzt über längere Zeit stabil ist und du weißt,
der ändert die ganze Zeit seine eine Verbindung, dann weißt du irgendwann,
da sitzt dieser Server oder da sitzt diese Person.
Und das hat in dem Boys Town Ermittlungsverfahren, haben das offenbar deutsche
Polizeibehörden in internationaler Zusammenarbeit an einigen Stellen geschafft
und haben da geht es um ein,
Strafermittlungsverfahren wegen Verbreitung dokumentierten Kindesmissbrauchs
und da sind eben diese Angriffe, diese Timing-Analysen erfolgreich eingesetzt worden.
Bis zu dem Punkt, dass du dann irgendwann sagst, jetzt gucken wir mal,
jetzt müssen wir nur noch beim Internetprovider fragen, wer zu einem gegebenen
Zeitpunkt mit einem bestimmten Tor-Entry verbunden ist.
Dann hast du irgendwie so und so viele, die das sind und dann sagst du,
alles klar und jetzt wollen wir gerne wissen, wer ungefähr einen Gigabyte Empfang
hat an dem Tag und dann weißt du, alles klar, da müssen wir klingeln.
Riesige Operation und es wurde bei Tor immer davon ausgegangen,
dass es irgendwie, das wird schon keinem gelingen.
Es wurden aber auch keine wirklichen brauchbaren Gegenmaßnahmen ergriffen.
Gegenmaßnahmen wären natürlich, random Delays einzuführen.
Also quasi deine Requests sind sowieso schon mal einfach zufällig zwischen einer
und acht Sekunden verzögert.
Und wenn du jetzt versuchst, Timing zu korrelieren, weißt du immer nicht,
ob die Verzögerung jetzt gerade daherkommt, weil du da eingesetzt hast Oder
weil einfach zufällig eine Verzögerung eingebaut wurde.
Eine andere Möglichkeit wäre, um halt Datenmengen-Korrelationen zu verhindern,
dass du halt Cover-Traffic hast.
Das heißt, du kommunizierst nicht nur das über das Tor-Netzwerk,
was dich wirklich interessiert und was du brauchst, sondern du sendest die gesamte
Zeit überall irgendwelchen Mist hin.
Damit nämlich am Ende du nicht mehr über die Datenmenge identifizierbar bist,
sondern du gehst im Prinzip hin und sagst, ich schalte jetzt Tor ein und Tor
macht, sagen wir mal, Basistraffic 10 Mbit.
Und wenn ich jetzt was haben will, was ein Mbit oder was eine Pro-Zeit-Einheit
ist, dann füllt es den Rest auf oder nimmt halt die maximale Bandbreite.
Aber man kann quasi nicht mehr an meinem Anschluss erkennen,
ob ich online bin oder ob ich gerade etwas tue oder nicht.
Das wären so die beiden naheliegendsten Methoden, die aber natürlich eine Maß
dazu führen würden, dass Thor massiv Datenmüll hin und her schiebt und langsamer wird.
Das sind die beiden Gründe, warum Thor das nie gemacht hat. Die Vorschläge gibt
es so lange, wie es Thor gibt.
Ja, und das ist halt quasi auch in deren Threadmodel, ja, da steht ja auch,
da steht ja drin, dass das gehen kann und dass man davon ausgeht,
dass es keiner hinkriegt.
Ist halt jetzt ein bisschen doof, wenn es jemand hinkriegt.
Vor allem, weil es eben eine relativ umfassende Kontrolle des umliegenden Netzwerks erfordert.
Also man muss ja dann wirklich an sehr vielen Stellen schauen und üblicherweise
hast du eben sehr viele unterschiedliche Teilnehmer dann dort zu koordinieren.
Also verschiedene Internetprovider auf verschiedenen Ebenen,
verschiedene Staaten gegebenenfalls auch.
Umso globaler das aufgezogen wird, potenziell ja irgendwann mal die ganze Welt.
Und da kann ich schon nachvollziehen, dass man das dann erstmal als schwierig
ansieht, hier diesen Aufwand zu treiben.
Aber offensichtlich kann es eben gelingen.
Insbesondere, wenn sich sowas innerhalb eines Landes abspielt.
Der Fehler, genau, also du hast jetzt gesagt, innerhalb eines Landes,
das versucht Thor natürlich massiv zu verhindern.
Also das Protokoll ist schon so, dass du versuchst, über Jurisdiktionen zu springen.
Also zum Beispiel, wenn du jetzt sagst, also ich nehme jetzt ein hypothetisches
Beispiel, du fängst an in den USA, springst einmal nach Russland und kommst
dann, was weiß ich, in Schweden wieder raus.
Ja, dann würdest du davon ausgehen, dass die USA und Russland nicht kooperieren.
Und das ist quasi, dass das, dadurch springst du, also du versuchst auf gar
keinen Fall, springst du dreimal in Deutschland hin und her,
weil da weißt du, okay, potenziell gibt es hier jemanden, der das alles unter Kontrolle hat.
Was das aber die ganze Zeit, das muss ich auch sagen, das kritisiere ich auch
schon eigentlich, seit ich Tor kenne, was das nicht berücksichtigt ist,
dass natürlich, sagen wir mal, eine staatliche Organisation problemlos massenhaft
Serverkapazitäten in jedem Land dieser Erde mieten kann.
Ja und das, also nur weil der Server in, in, was weiß ich, sagen wir mal St.
Petersburg steht, heißt das ja nicht, dass der nicht von der CIA oder von der
NSA oder sonst wem bezahlt wurde.
Und dass die den Traffic, der da durchfließt, nicht wegschreiben und analysieren
oder die Verbindung, die das Ding herstellt und darüber Statistiken machen.
Und das war glaube ich immer so ein bisschen der Fehler. Und das Tornetz ist
groß, aber es ist auch nicht so groß, dass es jetzt unmöglich wäre,
nennenswerte Kapazitäten davon selber beizutragen.
Tor geht zum Beispiel, wenn du jetzt so ein Tor, ich habe das ja jahrelang selber
auch betrieben, inzwischen mache ich das nicht mehr, aber wenn du jetzt mehrere
Relays hast, was ich hatte, dann ist das ein Fehler.
Dann wirst du gebeten, auch zu sagen, dass die zu einer Familie gehören.
Und im Prinzip dem Netz zu sagen, übrigens, diese Relays, die gehören alle mir.
Wenn ihr ein Circuit über eines dieser Relays aufbaut, versucht mal,
die anderen aus meiner Familie nicht zu benutzen.
Weil sonst kommt...
Wenn du kompromittiert bist und so.
Genau, sonst habe ich eine Möglichkeit, euch zu... Oder ich könnte halt,
aber das ist natürlich eine freiwillige Angabe, die kannst du auch falsch machen.
Und wenn man sich überlegt, was das jetzt kostet, so das Tornetz wird ja größtenteils
von Idealisten dann da betrieben mit irgendwelchen Spenden oder sonst was.
Wenn du jetzt überlegst, da geht man so eine staatliche Institution hin und.
Sagt so, wir haben jetzt mal hier Budget, kauft mal einfach nennenswert Torkapazität,
würden die potenziell nur dadurch auffallen, dass auf einmal ganz viele Server dazukommen.
Dann würde man halt im Tor-Netz sagen, ey, was ist denn hier los?
Überall auf der Welt nehmen gleichzeitig die Server-Kapazitäten zu.
Da würden wir mal fragen, wer denn dahinter steckt. Und das ist auch bei Tor
gehört schon zu Due Diligence, wenn du da irgendwie massenhafter Exit-Betreiber bist.
Bevor das Netz sehr viel zu dir routet und dir quasi mit viel Traffic vertraut,
passiert da eine ganze Zeit was.
Und dann wird halt geguckt, ob man dir vertrauen kann oder so.
Also nach meiner Wahrnehmung, also Fazit, Hidden Services betreiben ...
Ist jetzt, also es ist ja auch nicht, wäre nicht der erste Hidden Service,
der demaskiert wird. Das passiert ja eher sehr häufig und sehr schnell.
Sehr häufig und in schneller Folge. Das ist, würde ich nicht mehr machen,
wenn ich Angst haben muss, dass ich als, dass ich irgendwo in der organisierten
Kriminalität tätig bin oder,
massive staatliche Kapazitäten gegen mich stehen habe.
Und das ist jetzt für Kriminelle eine Sache, aber zum Beispiel auch für die
Dissidentinnen, Journalistinnen und so weiter, für die Tor gebaut wird,
ist das eben potenziell dann doch lebensgefährlich.
Wenn du jetzt irgendwie unter deinem Tor Hidden Service aus deinem,
keine Ahnung, aus deiner Wohnung in Shanghai deine,
regimekritischen, aufruhrerischen Texte verteilst, dann musst du davon ausgehen,
dass auch China in der Lage ist, früher oder später diesen Server zu lokalisieren
und dich fertig zu machen.
Und da müsste jetzt eigentlich mal was passieren.
Gleichzeitig muss man auch sagen, für für die ganz normale Tornutzerin,
die mal, was weiß ich, auf Facebook guckt oder grundsätzlich beim Internet surfen,
den Tor-Browser verwendet oder so, die hat da überhaupt keine Änderung ihrer
Bedrohungslage, die da jetzt entstehen würde.
Ja.
Alright.
Es gab also vielleicht noch eine Kleinigkeit, wenn man sich den Thor-Blogpost
dazu anschaut, sind die ein bisschen,
also diese Sache wurde veröffentlicht von dem NDR glaube ich,
der Journalist Daniel Moosbrugger setzt sich seit,
ja ich glaube schon immer halt mit Thor, Anonymisierung, Darknet und solchen Dingen auseinander.
Und hat bei der Einschätzung dieser Dokumente eben auch vom Chaos Computer Club
Sachverständige gefragt,
ob sie diese Dokumente einsehen können, seine Interpretationen teilen,
ob das vielleicht was anderes ist oder was wurde da gemacht.
Da holt sie ja technische Sachverständige. Und das Tor-Projekt ist jetzt ein bisschen verschnupft,
dass offenbar Leute vom CCC diese Dinge gesehen haben und das Tor-Projekt andere
Dinge gezeigt bekommen hat von dem Journalisten.
Also offenbar, also ich weiß ja nicht, was der Journalist dem Torprojekt gezeigt
hat, aber die behaupten irgendwie, Leute vom CCC hätten mehr gesehen als sie, ja.
Würde ich mal vorsichtig anmerken, Leute vom CCC sagen auch schon sehr lange,
dass Thor mal Cover-Traffic und Random-Delays anbieten sollte.
Und es ist natürlich eine schwierige Situation, wenn du jetzt halt für einen
Journalisten als Sachverständiger gefragt wirst und der dir sagt,
diese Informationen zeige ich dir, du darfst damit niemandem drüber reden,
weil das für meinen Quellenschutz relevant ist.
Dann machst du das natürlich auch nicht das ist ja genauso ein Wert von uns
dass wenn wir wenn wir unter Maßgabe des Quellenschutzes zum Stillschweigen
gebeten werden dann müssen wir dem natürlich auch entsprechen,
und für das Torprojekt dürfte jetzt ehrlich gesagt das Ganze nicht.
Also ich glaube nicht, dass sie irgendwelche großartige Informationen Informationen
brauchten, außer dass es halt diesen Beleg gab.
Also das finde ich ein bisschen erstaunlich.
Sie haben einen Blogpost, in dem sie erklären, für die normale Tornutzerin besteht
kein Risiko, hat sich nichts geändert, gehen Sie bitte weiter,
hier gibt es nichts zu sehen.
Das stimmt, ja, ist in Ordnung so, aber dann zu sagen, mi, mi,
mi, der Angriff, von dem wir in unserem Threat Model wissen,
seitdem Tor definiert wurde, hat stattgefunden und der Journalist hat uns nicht alles gesagt,
inspiriert bei mir jetzt nicht so ein Vertrauen.
Ja, also wenn ich bei anderen Leuten sehe,
wie sie über ihre Schwachstellen oder Angriffe auf ihre Systeme sprechen und
dann ist auf einmal der Journalist schuld, das bewertet man gemeinhin als etwas unsouverän.
In der Branche. Ja. Gleichzeitig zeigen sie natürlich, dass sie etwas dagegen
tun wollen und natürlich Informationen haben wollen.
Also ja, alles läuft so, wie es laufen muss.
Tor hat eine hohe Verantwortung, werden dieser Verantwortung gerecht,
geben sich da sehr viel Mühe.
Aber ja, eine nach, weiß gar nicht, wie lange es Tor jetzt gibt,
sind das schon 20 Jahre wahrscheinlich, ne?
Gute Frage Weiß gar nicht.
Wann habe ich angefangen Wir haben jetzt 2024,
Weiß gar nicht, wann vor 2002 sagt das Internet Also seit 20 Jahren wird dieses
Ding genutzt Dann ist das auch normal, dass irgendwann mal,
sicherheitsrelevante Annahmen sich ändern ändern.
20. September 2002. Wir haben heute gar nicht das Datum gesagt.
Heute ist der 22. September. Das ist wirklich ziemlich genau. 22 Jahre jetzt.
Meine Güte.
Tja, muss man sehen.
Dafür hat es ziemlich gut gehalten.
Das stimmt. Es gibt nicht viele Projekte, die so lange durchhalten.
Zumal ja Open Source Projekte so generell ihre Probleme haben jetzt mit der
Talent Retention und so weiter und der Finanzierung.
Das ist ja ein Thema, was weit über Tor hinaus ein Problem ist.
Das wir ja hier auch schon ein paar Mal angesprochen haben. Na egal.
Aber also abschließend noch mal für euch für euch hat sich nichts geändert.
Und da hat Tor schon auch recht. Wenn ihr mit dem Tor-Browser oder dem Onion-Browser oder was auch immer,
eure alltäglichen Anonymitätsbedarf abdeckt, dann hat sich da nichts geändert.
Wenn ihr Ricochet nutzt, okay, das ist aber eh tatsächlich inzwischen auch,
also dass es diese Angriffsfläche hatte, war auch bekannt und ist auch,
glaube ich, inzwischen wird Ricochet gar nicht mehr weiterentwickelt.
Also für die normale Tornutzerin und Torgelegenheitsnutzerin die nicht irgendwie
einen Hidden Service betreibt der potenziell bei Deanonymisierung ihr Leben
oder ihre Freiheit bedroht hat sich nichts geändert.
Ja gut wollen wir dann.
Weitermachen ja können wir weitermachen ja Ja.
Wo kommen eigentlich die ganzen schlechten Nachrichten her?
Also was man ja heutzutage lernen muss, ist so der Unterschied zwischen Missinformation
und Desinformation unter anderem, sollte man zumindest.
Ja, kannst du nochmal erklären? Das eine ist das einzelne Element und das andere
ist strukturiert, oder?
Naja, sagen wir mal so, Missinformation ist einfach falsch.
Das ist einfach eine falsche Information, die dir vermittelt wird und die einfach nicht stimmt.
Und dann gibt es noch Desinformation und das ist eben falsche Information mit
der Intention, dich eben in eine bestimmte Richtung zu drücken,
mit dieser Information, dich also aktiv zu beeinflussen.
Und während wir ja schon immer wussten, dass das Internet voll von falschen
Informationen ist, weil sie heute einfach nicht besser wissen,
aber trotzdem einfach sagen,
weil sie das so denken und man natürlich gerne überprüfen würde,
ob irgendwas stimmt, ist es bei Desinformation eben so, dass es eben konkret
als Waffe eingesetzt wird.
Um dir irgendein Gefühl zu geben, um dich in irgendeine Richtung zu lenken,
um dich etwas glauben zu machen, was am Ende vielleicht zu deinem eigenen Nachteil sein kann, all das.
Und in den ganzen Kriegen und Konflikten, die wir derzeit haben,
spielt es in zunehmendem Maße eine große Rolle. Rolle, nicht nur in den Kriegen,
sondern vor allem eben auch mittlerweile in Wahlkämpfen, wie wir das ja jetzt
schon mehrfach erlebt haben.
Wir haben ja auch schon darüber gesprochen, Brexit, die Trump-Wahl,
all diese ganzen Ereignisse waren begleitet von viel falschen Informationen,
aber eben auch von viel Desinformation. Informationen.
Und ja, speziell Russland ist bekannt dafür, in diesem Segment richtig aktiv unterwegs zu sein.
Und das geben sie ja auch selber gerne zu.
Also das ist ja überhaupt gar kein Geheimnis. Da muss man nur mal auf ihre Fernsehkanäle
schalten, was sie da alles so von sich geben.
Gerade jüngst hat sich die Chefin von RT...
Und gebrüstet damit, was sie ja dann doch für großartige Aktionen macht und
mit relativ wenig Geld große Erfolge erzielt im Westen und damit sozusagen den
Informationsfluss in der Öffentlichkeit komplett derailed.
Ja, das finden die ganz toll.
Da klopfen die sich richtig öffentlich drauf auf die Schulter.
Und von daher ist es jetzt auch keine große Überraschung, zumindest für mich
nicht, jetzt hier zu lesen, was WDR,
NDR und Süddeutsche Zeitung ausgegraben haben über die sogenannte Social Design Agency, SDA.
Ja, eine Gruppe innerhalb Russlands, die aktiv darauf arbeitet,
eben genau solche Desinformationen im Westen zu betreiben.
Und noch weniger überraschend wird hier durch verschiedene Unterlagen,
auf die sie gestoßen sind,
die Information veröffentlicht, dass Deutschland hier ein besonders lohnenswertes Ziel zu sein scheint,
weil es irgendwie einfacher ist, die Deutschen für die russische Ideologie einzunehmen,
als es jetzt vielleicht mit manchen anderen europäischen Ländern der Fall ist.
Ich glaube, was ja hier so schon noch sehr interessant ist an dieser Veröffentlichung
ist, dass es da bis in die KPIs geht.
Also sie sagen ja hier, diese SDA,
das ist irgendwie eine Firma, so eine Firma hat Ziele und wenn es möglich ist,
werden in Firmen Ziele auch irgendwie greifbar oder messbar gemacht.
Mit KPIs, Key Performance Indicators oder OKRs, Operational Key Results.
Das könnte man dann sagen, das ist ein wichtiger Meilenstein dieses Unternehmens.
Und die KPIs der Social Design Agency sind irgendwie Erhöhung des Stimmenanteils
der AfD, Zunahme des Indikators Zukunftsangst.
Der Indikator sollte in Umfragen möglichst bei mehr als 50 Prozent liegen.
Mehr als 55 Prozent sollten außerdem nicht bereit sein, ihr Vermögen zu opfern,
um Russland zu besiegen.
Dann irgendwie Polarisierung der deutschen Gesellschaft, Zurückhaltung bei der
Wahl der Grünen bei über 40 Prozent.
Und thematische Linien, irgendwie Deutschland sei unbewaffnet,
die USA würden antirussische Maßnahmen nutzen,
um Deutschland gezielt in den Bankrott zu treiben, Deutschland befinde sich
in der tiefsten wirtschaftlichen und sozialen Krise der jüngeren Geschichte.
Also schon relativ klar.
Das ist irgendwie faszinierend, aber genau so würdest du das halt machen.
Wenn du eine Lobbyorganisation hast, die öffentliche Wahrnehmung beeinflussen
soll, dann machst du das ja auch.
Dann sagst du auch, pass auf, unsere KPIs sind die Ergebnisse in der Sonntagsfrage
oder zu irgendeinem Thema.
Wir wollen, dass die Leute, also wenn du Werbung machst, ist das ja auch so.
Es wird gesagt, ich möchte, so und so viele Leute mehr sollen unser Produkt
kaufen oder sollen für oder gegen Sozialhilfe, Erhöhungen, Absenkungen,
Flüchtlinge rein, raus.
Das ist ja relativ klar. Das messbare Output sind dann eben Umfragen.
Aber es ist schon auch echt krass, dass es in Russland eine Organisation gibt,
die zum Ziel hat, messbar die Zukunftsangst der deutschen Bevölkerung zu erhöhen.
Methoden, wie sie das macht, und da sind natürlich vielfältig,
sehr viel auch Social Media, Karikaturen, die da gezeichnet werden.
Russia Today ist natürlich auch ein relativ klares Outlet.
Jetzt werden auch sicherlich Leute argumentieren, die Amerikaner machen das
seit jeher, hast du nicht gesehen.
Aber ja, tun sie. Aber es ist natürlich trotzdem relativ interessant,
wenn man sich dann auch noch anschaut, naja, der AfD-Stimmanteil,
der nähert sich 20 Prozent und die Zukunftsangst der Deutschen ist sicherlich
auch, also die erreichen ihre KPIs halt gerade auch.
Und selbst wenn man jetzt davon ausgehen würde, dass das alles nicht,
also ich stelle mir jetzt gerade vor, ich wäre so Sarah Wagenknecht oder Björn
Höcke oder irgendein anderer Durchgeknallter oder jemand noch Durchgeknallter,
jemand, der die gut findet.
Dann würde ich natürlich sagen, aber es ist ja nun mal so, aber dann kann man
wenigstens noch sagen, okay, wenigstens erkennen wir jetzt, dass die Entwicklung,
in der Deutschland sich gerade befindet, 100% im Interesse Russlands ist.
Ja, also dass wir quasi, wir erreichen gerade die KPIs für irgendwelche professionellen
Deutschland-Kaputtmacher in Russland.
Ja, wir erreichen das gerade. Wir sind voll auf der Linie eines Terrorstaats.
Und das ist schon krass. Jetzt kann ich mir auch vorstellen,
wahrscheinlich würde ich dann sagen, ja, das ist ein Fake. Die haben einfach mal alles genommen,
was ihnen gerade nicht gefällt. Und jetzt soll auch noch der Russe schuld sein.
Dabei ist es in Wirklichkeit die Wärmepumpe.
Insofern ist natürlich diese Publikation, Ich fand spannend,
dass sie bei weitem nicht die Wahrnehmung und Reichweite hatte,
die ich ihr zugetraut hätte.
Aber das liegt wahrscheinlich auch daran, dass halt irgendwie Sarah Wagenknecht
bei ihren 84 Talkshow-Auftritten letzte Woche irgendwie nicht behandelt hat, das Thema.
Ja, naja, also das ist hochproblematisch. Ich sehe auch gerade diese ganze BSW-Bewegung
als sehr problematisch an, weil sie auch bei ihren ganzen Veranstaltungen zu
dem Thema Frieden, in Anführungsstrichen,
ja im Wesentlichen einfach genau die russischen Talking Points runterrattern. rattern.
Also für die heißt doch Frieden, dass die Ukraine sich einfach überfallen lässt
und endlich aufhört sich zu wehren.
Ja, genau.
Das ist doch der geiler Frieden.
Ja, der Frieden ist ja sozusagen nur der einzige Frieden, über den ihr geredet
würdet. Ja, für Deutschland.
Es ist auch so anstrengend, immer mit dem Krieg und so weiter dem zuzuhören
und so voll anstrengend.
Das wollen wir jetzt mal wegmachen. Könnt ihr mal aufhören mit Krieg.
Gebt doch einfach auf. Das wird halt nicht stattfinden.
Also das ist, ich will mich ja zu diesen Themen zurückhalten, ja, aber.
Na gut, ich meine, wir werden dieses Thema, also es ist ja auch nicht nur Deutschland.
Also diese Trollfabriken in Russland, die gibt es ja schon länger und diese
Organisation kriegt jetzt das erste Mal einen Namen.
Zusammen, es gibt da jetzt auch eine andere Person, die da in Charge ist,
das war ja noch vor einem Jahr alles so ein bisschen unter der Fuchtel von diesem
Prigorschin, der ja dann diese Wagner-Truppen angeführt hat in Russland,
sich dann aber gegen Putin gestellt hat und dann mal so ein bisschen defenestriert wurde,
indem da sein Flugzeug abgeschossen wurde, indem er drin saß.
Und jetzt musste das halt jemand anders übernehmen, wie heißt der Typ?
Ilja Gamba Schietze, klingt eher nach einem georgischen Namen,
Auf jeden Fall haben die Russen nie aufgehört, das zu betreiben und dieser Apparat ist im Betrieb.
Es gab auch noch eine andere relativ weit gestreute Meldung vor kurzem erst,
dass RT nachgewiesen wurde,
dass sie über versteckte Zahlungen so eine YouTube-Publikationsgruppe namens
T-Net Media finanziert hat.
Und das waren auch so sechs, sieben, acht verschiedene YouTuber,
die halt so diese typischen politischen Kommentarshows machen,
wo sie also auch wirklich rauf und runter nur die russischen Talking Points
zum Ukraine-Krieg veröffentlicht haben.
Ja, die Ukraine ist der Feind der USA und so weiter.
Also wirklich so volles Brett, ohne irgendwie da mit irgendwas zurückzuhalten.
Ja, und die sind dann also teilweise mit hohen Millionenbeträgen gefördert worden,
obwohl die auch noch relativ niedrige Zuschaltzahlen haben.
Es waren jetzt also keine Big Shots im YouTube-Business, wenn man das mal so
vergleicht, so mit fünfstelligen Abrufzahlen teilweise bei den Videos,
nur was für YouTube eigentlich gar nichts ist.
Aber darum geht es auch gar nicht, sondern es geht eben in dieser ganzen Geschichte
immer um die Zerstörung des Diskurses. Das ist das Ziel der Russen.
Sie wollen, dass wir gar nicht mehr in der Lage sind, überhaupt noch nennenswert eine Debatte zu führen.
Das ist sozusagen die Auslöschung der Wahrheit.
Nichts ist mehr wahr.
Gar nichts kann mehr stimmen und es wird allem irgendwie misstraut,
weil man im Internet ja auch zu allem irgendwie schon mal eine Gegenthese gelesen hat.
Und es ist immer sehr interessant das zu verfolgen, irgendwas passiert und du
kannst einfach die Uhr danach stellen,
das dauert dann bestenfalls zwei, drei, vier Stunden und dann hast du einfach
so eine Bot-Armee von Twitter-Accounts, die loslegen und zu diesem Ereignis
eine passende These darlegen, warum da jetzt die USA,
die Ukraine oder wer auch immer dahinter steckt.
Und das sind halt einfach diese Methoden, mit denen hier gearbeitet wird im
industriellen Maßstab. Das kann man nicht anders sagen.
Also es ist sozusagen die einzige Aufgabe dieser Organisationen,
das ist sicherlich nicht nur eine oder vielleicht ist es auch eben ein Verbund,
der gemeinsam geführt wird, das weiß ich nicht so ganz genau.
Aber RT, SDA, wie auch immer sie heißen, deren Hauptaufgabe ist es,
den westlichen Diskurs komplett zu zerlegen.
Und das gelingt ihnen einfach viel zu gut.
Was sehr viel mit unserer Gutgläubigkeit zu tun hat, aber eben auch mit unserer
Ignoranz gegenüber solchen Vorgängen.
Ist das unsere Gutgläubigkeit? Ich dachte, das sind diese ganzen,
die mal selber versuchen mit dem Denken.
War das nicht so? Kommen sie ja alle super klug vor.
Ich kann ihnen das auch gar nicht so sehr, also ist immer leicht sozusagen auf
die Gutgläubigkeit von Leuten einzuschlagen, weil man ja selber so toll und so klug ist.
Ich gebe zu, auch ich habe solche Momente gehabt,
wo ich dachte so, das kann doch alles gar nicht wahr sein und da steckt doch
bestimmt noch mehr dahinter und so mit Verschwörungstheorien zu arbeiten und das irgendwie,
ja so klug zu sein.
Nein, ich durchschaue das, da ist irgendwie mehr dahinter und so einfach kann
es nicht gewesen sein und die wollen da bestimmt nur irgendwas vertuschen.
Das ist so ein Gefühl, dem kann man sich sehr schnell hingeben,
weil es halt automatisch auch so dieses Narrativ bedient mit,
ich durchschaue die Welt wirklich, hört doch mal auf mich, ich bin ja.
Toll. Und dann hast du halt auch schnell so eine Gruppe von Leuten,
die dann dasselbe Narrativ bedient und die sich dann darauf so einlassen und
dann merkst du so, wir sind aber
auch viele und jetzt tun wir uns hier zusammen und glaubt uns doch nur.
Bis du natürlich dann in so einen Wahn verfällst, in dem einfach alles nur noch
hinterfragt wird, gar nichts mehr richtig sein darf und es nur noch darum geht,
zu beweisen, dass du da total den Durchblick hast und alle anderen sind einfach nur dumme Schafe.
Und dann ist es irgendwann auch vollkommen egal, an was du glaubst,
Hauptsache du glaubst überhaupt noch an irgendetwas.
Und das erklärt dann halt auch so Phänomene wie flache Erde,
wo man so davorsteht und sagt, Leute, geht's noch irgendwie?
Ist noch alles klar bei euch?
Ja, das heißt sehr offensichtlich, dass die Erde flach ist.
Also ich meine, wenn man hinten festbleibt, das würde ich völlig absurde vorstellen.
So, und du fragst dich halt, wie kann das überhaupt noch ein Ding sein?
Aber Leute sind dann einfach auch so gesellschaftlich dann auch schon so ausgegrenzt,
dass sie daran halt festhalten, weil das dann irgendwann nur noch alles ist,
was ihre Identität ausmacht.
Jetzt sind wir jetzt, was die Diskussionen um den Ukraine-Krieg betrifft,
vielleicht noch nicht so weit, dass wir da so auf Flat-Earth-Theorien landen,
aber es ist halt mittlerweile auch schon so eine.
Standardreaktion, dass wenn du einfach auch nur irgendwas berichtest und sagst,
das und das ist jetzt passiert, so, nee, weil schon über die Facebook-Gruppen,
die Telegram-Gruppen und,
in welcher Bubble du dann auch immer drinsteckst, es einfach nicht lange dauert,
bis irgendein Narrativ bedient wird und das wird halt sehr schnell Also es dauert keine zwei,
drei Stunden und dann ist schon irgendeine Erklärung, die in dein bisher schon
gebildetes Weltbild reinpasst, was du dann einfach dazu mischst und dann ist
das halt einfach so und du glaubst einfach gar keiner Berichterstattung mehr.
Und das ist genau diese Funktion von Desinformation und man muss einfach mal
akzeptieren, das funktioniert leider viel zu gut.
Und wir sind da auf dem, ja nicht nur auf dem Radar, wir sind da in der Zielscheibe
Russlands und das ist einfach ein Teil eines,
man könnte jetzt sagen Cyberwars, ein hybrider Cyberwar vielleicht sogar auch,
der aus vielen Komponenten besteht und da gehört eben auch eben diese soziale Komponente,
also im Sinne von die Social Network basierte Komponente mit dazu,
plus halt Massenmedien.
Es gehört halt hier noch ein, also was die ganze Sache halt echt ein bisschen
noch wirklich richtig unheimlich macht ist, das ist eine Angriffsfläche, die Russland nicht hat.
Wenn da einer irgendwie anfängt, zu groß rumzunörgeln am lokalen Narrativ von
Wladimir Putin, dann trinkt er auf einmal den falschen Tee, ist im Arbeitslager
und fällt da auf einmal tot um. Warum?
Das heißt, könnte ja sein, sagt Deutschland jetzt, pass auf Leute,
jetzt nehmen wir mal ein ähnliches Budget und dann versuchen wir mal den Rückhalt
für Wladimir Putin durch Berichterstattung zu schwächen.
Oder überhaupt die Bevölkerung für Narrative empfänglich zu machen.
Ich will jetzt noch gar nicht von Wahrheit oder Unwahrheit sprechen.
Überhaupt mal Inhaltskampagnen, Meinungsmanipulationskampagnen oder Meinungslenkungskampagnen
größeren Ausmaßes in Russland zu machen,
das werden nicht so viele überleben.
Das heißt, diese Angriffsfläche, öffentliche Meinung, Aufklärung oder eben auch
massenhafte Täuschung, da kann Wladimir Putin in Russland sagen,
da wird da auf jeden Fall ein Kampf, wo wir eine sehr viel größere Angriffsfläche haben als er.
Ja, genau. Also im Prinzip ist unser Vorteil, ist unser Nachteil.
Wir haben halt einfach eine offene Gesellschaft und einen offenen Medienbereich
und der ist natürlich sehr viel volatiler,
als es eben so ein streng unter die Kandare genommenes Medienimperium ist,
wie das eben jetzt in Russland herrscht.
Zusätzlich ist aber auch die russische Bevölkerung mittlerweile halt auch so
durchkonditioniert, dass sie halt sowieso gar nichts mehr glauben.
Weil es ist ja nicht so, Leute werden ja nicht nur festgenommen,
wenn sie sich auf den Platz stellen und gegen Putin demonstrieren.
Leute werden ja festgenommen, wenn sie sich auf den Platz stellen und überhaupt
für irgendwas demonstrieren.
Also das ist ja auch dieses schöne Beispiel mit dem weißen Schild.
Du stellst dich einfach mit einem weißen Schild hin.
Auf dem gar nichts steht und du wirst schon festgenommen. Es werden auch Leute
festgenommen, wenn sie für den Krieg demonstrieren.
Wo du dich fragst, wieso das denn? Weil es nicht darum geht, was du sagst.
Es geht darum, dass du was sagst. Du hast gar nicht teilzunehmen an diesem Diskurs.
Du hast einfach zu akzeptieren, der Staat macht das schon für sich alleine.
Deine Aufgabe ist dein Privatleben und deinen Job zu machen und aus allem anderen hältst du dich raus.
Das ist einfach, der Staat macht das schon und du hast gar nicht zu interferieren
mit irgendwelchen Ideen. Ja, Kampagnen für den Krieg, das machen wir auch selber,
das brauchst du gar nicht zu machen.
Es ist uns völlig egal, was deine Aussage ist, du hast einfach gar keine Aussage zu machen.
Dementsprechend verheilen dann natürlich auch Warnungen von außen,
weil die sich natürlich genauso in diese Situation bringen.
Wenn man sich so Interviews macht, das gerne in letzter Zeit,
Interviews einfach mit Leuten auf der Straße in Russland anschaut und die einfach
zu bestimmten Themen befragt, dann hast du sehr oft diese Reaktion,
dass wenn sie selber auf einmal das Gefühl haben,
dass ihre Antwort zu sehr in Politik reingreift, dass das Thema jetzt Politik ist,
dann sagen sie sehr schnell, da bin ich auch gar nicht kompetent,
das ist gar nicht so mein Bereich, da will ich mich gar nicht einmischen,
da sag ich jetzt mal gar nichts zu.
Weil sie einfach merken, das ist ein Feld, da sollen sie nicht sein.
Egal mit welcher Meinung.
Ja und das ist so ein Problem, dass wir einfach als Demokratie und als offenes
System da natürlich angreifbar sind.
Und diese Debatte, werden wir auch gleich im nächsten Teil noch sehen,
die ist problematisch und die wird auch problematisch bleiben.
Währenddessen verhaften wir in Europa die Freiheitskämpfer der verschlüsselten,
sicheren und unzensierten Kommunikation, Tim.
Tja, wenn es mal so wäre. Also, was ist passiert?
Pavel Durov ist in Frankreich von den französischen Behörden festgenommen worden,
als er mit seinem geilen Privatjet eingeritten ist in Paris.
Und ist eine Weile in U-Haft gewesen, ist es mittlerweile nicht mehr,
darf aber das Land nicht verlassen. Wer ist Pavel Durov?
Pavel Durov ist der Gründer, Chef von Telegram, von dem Messenger, der aus Russland kam.
Ich würde bei dieser Stelle übrigens noch kurz auf LNP 399 Darknet für die Hosentasche,
verweisen, wo wir nämlich mit dem Max Hoppenstedt darüber gesprochen haben,
der ja Pavel Durov schon immer quasi begleitet und da haben wir glaube ich sehr viel uns über Telegram,
Pavel Durov und so weiter unterhalten.
Ich glaube, da hatte er sogar dann gerade eine Spiegel-Titel- Geschichte zu Telegram.
Diese Sendung war nur zur Einordnung am 18.
Juni 2021. 2021, genau.
Max ist beim Netzwelt-Resort des Spiegels und also Telegram ist,
also ich würde sagen, er ist einfach derjenige, der sich mit Abstand am meisten
und am längsten mit diesen ganzen Telegram-Thematiken auseinandergesetzt hat.
Der wird wahrscheinlich auch in unserer relativ schlechten Aufarbeitung dieses
Themas um die Pavel-Durow-Verhaftung noch einige Fehler finden oder wichtige
Sachen, die wir jetzt übersehen.
Max, schreib mir oder komm mal wieder in die Sendung.
Aber genau, da haben wir dieses Telegram-Ding nochmal ausführlich und da hat
er, glaube ich, auch noch relativ viel über Pavel Durov gesprochen.
Na, gucken wir mal, wie schlecht wir das jetzt eingefangen bekommen.
Also, er ist ja auch nicht nur der Chef von Telegram, sondern er hat ja auch
noch so einen Hintergrund.
Er hat ja auch in Russland diese V-Kontakte gestartet.
Also das ist schon immer so ein bisschen der, ich will jetzt keine persönlichen
Vergleiche machen, Aber wir
haben auch in den USA ja diverse einzelne Personen, meist Männer gesehen,
die halt irgendwie große Systeme aufgezogen sind und dann bejubelt wurden,
aber dann vielleicht auch mal in Probleme gekommen sind.
Ich glaube, der Gründungsmythos von Telegram ging so,
und wie gesagt, Gründungsmythen sind ja immer nur so halbwahr,
der sollte irgendwas pro-ukrainisches von V-Kontakte löschen,
dann hat er sich dagegen geweigert, dann standen sie bei ihm vor der Tür und
hatten irgendwie seine Systeme auch beeinträchtigt und dann ist ihm aufgefallen,
dass er überhaupt keinen sicheren Messenger hat.
Er hat jetzt quasi keine sichere Kommunikationsmethode mehr.
Und dann hat er gesagt, dann mache ich jetzt Telegram.
Genau, das ist so ein bisschen die Erzählung. Er hat dann auch die Tür nicht
aufgemacht und deswegen konnte ich dann nicht reinkommen.
Wobei, da habe ich schon so ein bisschen meine Zweifel.
In Russland, wenn die irgendwo rein wollen, dann naja.
Da muss er schon eine echt gute Tür gehabt haben.
Genau, also weiß man jetzt nicht so ganz genau und das ist halt auch so ein
bisschen schon so eins dieser Probleme, die mit dieser Person Pavel Durov einhergehen.
Er ist halt jetzt nicht mehr in Russland, er sitzt in Dubai,
er hat neben seiner russischen Stadt… Ne.
Der sitzt in Paris.
Ja, jetzt sitzt er in Paris, aber Telegram und sein Unternehmen und sein offizieller
Aufenthaltsort ist eigentlich Dubai.
Wobei, er ist in der Zwischenzeit, also ich weiß nicht, ob ihm seine russische
Staatsbürgerschaft genommen wurde, ich glaube nicht, aber er hat sich dann auch noch eine von St.
Kitts und Nevis gekauft, weil macht man ja immer so, ne?
Hast du bestimmt auch irgendeine Staatsbürgerschaft bei irgendeinem Karibik-Staat, oder?
Ja, aber auch für die aus steuerlichen Gründen. Ja, ja, das kann ich mir auch vorstellen.
Das ist sicherlich auch bei der Staatsbürgerschaft UAE.
Jetzt auch so Staatsbürgerschaft in UAE, also in den Vereinigten Arabischen
Emiraten, das ist so Dubai, Abu Dhabi, die kriegt man jetzt auch nicht mal so
eben, sondern da musst du schon besondere Verdienste für das Land haben.
Da kannst du nicht einfach einen Antrag schreiben und sagen,
ich sitze jetzt hier schon seit drei Monaten, ich will jetzt mal Staatsbürger werden.
Nee, nee, nee, nee, nee. Da musst du schon quasi deinen Wert nachgewiesen haben für das Land.
Und dann können solche Anträge gestellt werden etc.
Also das scheint bei ihm alles passiert zu sein und Telegram wird halt von Dubai
aus orchestriert und dort mit einem, wie man meint, relativ überschaubaren Stamm an Technikern.
Ja, Milliardäre haben das aber nie so schwer, ihren Wert für das Land aufzunehmen.
Zu, unter Beweis zu stellen.
Ist richtig, aber sagen wir mal so, da geht es nicht nur um Geld,
sondern da geht es auch, sagen wir mal, um die Perspektive mit,
das, was die da tun, schadet UAE nicht.
Also mit anderen Worten.
Kein Klimaaktivist.
Es ist, naja, sagen wir mal so, was so die Kritisierung,
also andere Länder haben ja, und das ist ja das Hauptproblem,
was auch Deutschland mit Telegram hatte und in dem Fall auch Frankreich,
ja, wenn da Dinge laufen, wo das Land ein Problem mit hat,
dann ist da halt niemand zu erreichen bei Telegram.
So, klopf, klopf, klopf, hier, könnt ihr uns mal helfen?
Und dieser, kein Anschluss, unter dieser Nummer.
Und das ist halt so eins der Probleme, haben wir ja auch schon mal drüber gesprochen,
wie auch Deutschland da ein bisschen im Kreis hüpft und was man denn nun tun
kann oder sollte auf europäischer Ebene zum Beispiel,
um dort halt Betreiber solcher Systeme mal in die Pflicht zu nehmen,
mitzuhelfen, wenn es um die Aufklärung geht von Straftaten zum Beispiel.
Und das scheint auch so ein bisschen der Anlass gewesen zu sein für die Franzosen,
dass die gesagt haben, den nehmen wir jetzt einfach mal fest.
Er hat übrigens auch die französische Staatsbürgerschaft.
Also hier sind wir schlecht.
Something might apply.
Er wurde dann nach Befragungen offenbar auch erstmal wieder aus der U-Haft entlassen,
darf aber bisher Frankreich nicht verlassen.
Jetzt wissen wir nicht so richtig genau, was da besprochen und ermittelt wurde
und wie die Franzosen gedenken, mit diesem Fall umzugehen.
Aber wer auf jeden Fall erstmal einen Tee nehmen musste, das sind die Russen.
Weil man natürlich jetzt befürchtet hat, dass die Franzosen sich da quasi den
Chef schnappen und zu was weiß ich für welchen Zusagen bringen.
Warum ist das jetzt für Russland ein Problem? Die haben den doch eigentlich
verjagt. Naja, ich glaube die Story ja nicht so ganz.
Also dass Telegram keinen Special Deal mit Russland hat.
Ich kann es mir nicht so richtig vorstellen. Wissen tue ich es natürlich auch nicht.
Auf jeden Fall ist die Realität diese, dass wenn du Telegram jetzt abschalten würdest,
dann würden halt nicht nur die Schwobler und Apokalypse-Propheten in Deutschland
durchdrehen, weil sie keinen Kanal mehr haben.
Es würde wahrscheinlich auch einfach die komplette Kommunikationsstruktur des
russischen Militärs zerstören.
Das wäre dann sozusagen der Pager-Anschlag auf die russischen Streitkräfte,
denn die haben gar kein wirklich richtig gut funktionierendes Kommunikationssystem
und verlassen sich im Ukraine-Krieg nachweislich teilweise sehr stark auf Telegram-Gruppen.
Also da werden wirklich Angriffe koordiniert über Telegram.
Und man muss natürlich auch dazu wissen, dass eben Gruppenkommunikation auf
Telegram nicht gut verschlüsselt ist.
Es gibt da zwar eine Ende-zu-Ende-Verschlüsselung, aber nur im Fall von einer
Person mit einer anderen Person Kommunikation.
Und auch da nicht standardmäßig aktiviert.
Also ein normaler Telegram-Chat, wenn ihr dann Kontakt nehmt und sagt Hallo, ist unverschlüsselt.
Und dann kann man den geschützten Chat machen, auch nur in bilateraler Kommunikation
und in Gruppenkommunikation sowieso nicht.
Also das ist ein ungeeignetes Kommunikationsmittel für private Kommunikation.
Also mit anderen Worten, die Leute, die Zugriff auf diese Telegram-Server haben…,
Die können diesen Krieg quasi in Echtzeit mitverfolgen.
Und naja, wie wir gerade schon besprochen haben, also Russland hat eigentlich,
sagen wir mal, ganz gute Kenntnis davon, wie das so ist mit der Sicherheit und
mit den ganzen Kanälen und mit der Information und der Desinformation.
Und man würde ja meinen, dass sie da jetzt nicht sich sofort so ohne weiteres
mal auf irgendeine Technologie verlassen, die, sagen wir mal zum Beispiel jetzt
unter der Kontrolle Frankreichs stehen würde.
Und da halt Frankreich mal abgesehen von dem Ukraine-Krieg ohnehin mit den Russen
nochmal so einen speziellen Beef hat derzeit,
so eine Sache über die ja wenig geredet wird, sind ja die ganzen Auseinandersetzungen
gerade im zentralafrikanischen oder nordzentralafrikanischen Gebiet,
Wo ja russische Söldnertruppen für diverse Regierungsumstürze gesorgt haben,
wie zum Beispiel in Niger etc.
Und die Franzosen langsam ihren kolonialen Zugriff auf alte Kolonien verhindern,
die rein zufälligerweise halt auch Lieferanten für das ganze Uran ihrer Atomkraftwerke sind.
Also das ist eine sehr heiße Story, von der aber irgendwie derzeit noch nicht
klar ist, was jetzt hier eigentlich genau die Stoßrichtung ist.
Geht es also wirklich nur um die Verfolgung von Kindermissbrauch,
Dokumentation oder geht es hier um mehr als das?
Es ist unklar. Es ist auf jeden Fall ein Bereich, den man noch verfolgen sollte.
Ja, also ich würde auch sagen, mit diesem Telegramm, das wird auf die eine oder
andere Weise irgendwann eine dramatische Eskalation finden. Sagen wir es mal so.
Es wurde ja schon vor Jahren in Deutschland dann gedroht, wir schalten das irgendwie ab oder so.
Oder wir sperren Telegramm, das ist irgendwie nie passiert. Da habe ich mich
damals schon gefragt, wie, ne, irgendeiner muss jetzt von dem Baum wieder runterklettern.
Entweder die Bundesregierung oder Pavel Durov, ja, irgendwie sind die einfach,
irgendwie haben die einfach gewartet, bis alle an dem Baum vorbeigegangen sind
und haben die Sache auf sich berufen lassen.
Dann gibt's, es gibt ja jetzt schon so irgendwelche Zusicherungen,
ja, ja, okay, bei den Kriminellen, da helfen wir euch jetzt mal so ein bisschen
oder sowas, ne, aber ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass es in zehn Jahren immer
noch genau so weitergehen wird.
Also in zehn Jahren ist irgendetwas anders. Wahrscheinlich ist in fünf Jahren irgendetwas anders.
Entweder Telegram voll verschlüsselt und richtig hardcore oder Telegram in nennenswerter
Zusammenarbeit mit den Behörden wie jeder andere Messenger auch.
Auch, also ich meine, du hast es relativ einfach, als wenn du halt schon mal
Ende-zu-Ende-Verschlüsselungen auch für Gruppen hast, kannst du ja nicht mehr so viel rausgeben.
Immer noch sehr interessante Informationen, die da anfallen,
aber eben zum Beispiel keine Kommunikationsinhalte mehr.
Aber irgendetwas wird da passieren. Also der Zustand, der jetzt gerade ist,
der ist, glaube ich, nicht, der ist nicht mehr lange stabil, glaube ich.
Ja, also zumindest was das Verhältnis zu Europa betrifft, was das Verhältnis
zu den Vereinigten Arabischen Emiraten betrifft, das ist glaube ich eine sehr
komplexe Geschichte, vielleicht nur mal so ein kleines Detail,
was auch nicht unbedingt jeder so auf dem Zeiger hat.
Also die Vereinigten Arabischen Emirate, wir nehmen das ja immer so wahr,
Dubai, Handel, Influencer und
so weiter, die sitzen da alle am Strand und tippen auf ihren Handys rum.
Das ist so ein bisschen die Wahrnehmung, die man hat von UAE.
Aber UAE ist halt mittlerweile auch militärisch ein nicht ganz zu unterschätzender
Player in dem ganzen Gebiet.
Unter anderem unterstützen sie ja den militärischen Teil, der ein Drittel des
Landes Jemen unter Kontrolle hat.
Der also quasi der südliche Teil, der an die Region grenzt, wo die Houthi-Rebellen sind,
die ja wiederum vom Iran und damit natürlich auch vom Russland unterstützt werden
und derzeit dem Westen dort Ärger machen.
Also das ist alles immer sehr miteinander verwoben und komplex und mir ist einfach
die Rolle, die Telegram in diesem ganzen Ding spielt,
unklar, aber sie ist wichtig.
Also es ist nicht einfach nur so Jette Nasa Internet Service.
Sondern kaum irgendetwas steckt derzeit tiefer drin in diesem ganzen Machtgeflecht
als dieses shady Unternehmen.
So, dann würde ich ehrlich gesagt jetzt versuchen, wir hätten eigentlich noch
ein relativ langes Gespräch anstehen über das sogenannte Sicherheitspaket.
Aber in Ermangelung von Zeit und vielleicht auch von Themen für die nächste
Sendung würde ich sagen, wir sprechen über das Sicherheitspaket lieber in einer
eigenen Sendung beim nächsten Mal.
Ja, weil das ist ja, also das sogenannte Sicherheitspaket, das würde ich jetzt
ungern so am Ende nochmal schnell drüber gehen, weil das ja wirklich schon auch
ein ziemlicher Irrsinn ist, der da gerade stattfindet.
Und würde mich stattdessen so mit kleineren Irrsinnen noch ein bisschen befassen.
Wäre das in deinem Sinne, Tim?
Ja. Dass wir das nochmal in der nächsten Sendung dann genauer besprechen,
vielleicht auch mit einem Gast oder einer Gästin, Gästin müssen wir sagen.
Nicht, dass uns die Themen ausgehen.
Nicht, dass uns die Themen ausgehen. Sparen wir uns also auf.
Ich befinde mich gerade im Ausland. Ich glaube, ich habe einen Pass dabei.
Also im europäischen Ausland.
Ich hoffe, dass ich wieder reinkomme.
Ansonsten bin ich dann halt im Staatenlos.
Also kann man sich ungefähr vorstellen, was wir davon halten.
Na gut, dann mal Endspurt hier.
Die Wahlsoftware hat wieder ein Thema gespielt. Und zwar gab es ja in Thüringen
einen sehr bedauerlichen Wahlunfall und dann obendrein noch Probleme mit der Wahlsoftware.
Und zwar wurde da bei der Landtagswahl am 1.
September zunächst eine falsche Sitzverteilung berechnet.
Die haben quasi auch die Formel oder den Algorithmus, nachdem die Sitzverteilung
berechnet wird, geändert.
Und am nächsten Tag haben sie den Fehler auch bemerkt und korrigiert.
Durch die Neuzuteilung mussten die rechtsextremen AfD und CDU jeweils einen
Sitz an SPD und Grüne abgeben.
Und mit diesem neuen Anteil von
nur noch 40 Sitzen hat die AfD ihre Sperrminorität im Landtag verloren.
Und jetzt kannst du dir vorstellen, weißt du, wenn du, du gehst ins Bett und
sagst, die Sitzverteilung sieht so und so aus, Endergebnis sieht so und so aus
und wir haben so und so viele Plätze und die AfD hat eine Sperrminorität und
einen Tag später geht der Landeswahlleiter hin und sagt, ach übrigens,
haben wir falsch gerechnet?
Ja, hier kurz korrigiert, doch nicht.
Der Schaden, der da entsteht. Also überleg mal,
was da jetzt wieder von den ganzen Flacherdlern und,
weißt du, das ist ein solcher Gau noch obendrauf, der so das Vertrauen in die
Wahlsysteme und in die Demokratie erschüttert.
Da wenn das nicht so gefährlich wäre, würde ich nach Thüringen fahren und dort
ein paar Ohrfeigen verteilen wie kannst du,
wenn du Landeswahlleiter bist wenn dir dieser hohe Akt der Wahl in der Demokratie
anvertraut wird und du legst so eine blöde Bauchlandung hin was soll das und,
das erinnert mich an die Bundestagswahl 2017,
wo Thorsten Schröder, Martin Tschirsich und ich ja die Software dort auch auseinandergenommen
hatten und auch katastrophale Sicherheitslücken in diesem ganzen System gefunden haben,
die aber nun gut niemand ausgenutzt hat außer uns.
Seitdem machen wir uns ja viel Gedanken darüber, was irgend solcher Software
anvertraut wird. Und da meldeten sich bei uns halt auch vor allem die Leute,
die schon viele Jahre vorher gesagt haben, mach doch diese Software Open Source.
Es spricht ja überhaupt nichts dagegen, die nicht Open Source zu machen.
Das Wahlergebnis ist ja wohl kaum geheim.
Und wenn du die Algorithmen, die da eben zur Auszählung und so weiter verwendet
werden, wenn du das alles offen machst,
dann ist das doch der Demokratie ein Dienst.
Dienst, ja, insbesondere wenn dann kompliziertere Auswahlverfahren,
Auszählverfahren zum Einsatz kommen, ja, wo dann irgendwie kumulieren,
panaschieren, was sie alles irgendwie machen, ne,
wäre doch naheliegend, es geht ja nicht nur um Sicherheitslücken,
sondern es geht eben auch um, ja, Fehler in der Auszählung.
Es sieht hier ein bisschen danach aus, dass die einfach die Konfiguration nicht
geändert hatten und die Sitzverteilung berechnet haben wie vier Jahre früher.
Aber kann man nur darüber spekulieren, wenn du da anfragst und sagst,
Thorsten hat das gemacht, hat gesagt, guten Tag, Chaos Computer Club,
mich würde mal interessieren, welche Software, in welcher Version haben sie denn da verwendet?
Dann sagen die, das können wir ihnen aus Sicherheitsgründen nicht sagen.
Muss ich mal überlegen.
Immerhin nicht aus Datenschutzgründen.
Ja, aber was für ein Scheiß. Ich meine, abgesehen davon, dass wir uns das eh
an einer Hand abzählen können. Ja.
Ist es doch wirklich, was willst du solchen Leuten,
also warum vertrauen wir solchen Leuten, wenn die solche,
also wenn sie quasi Raubbau am Vertrauen in die Wahl, in die IT-Systeme,
in den demokratischen Prozess aktiv befördern.
Das ist so verantwortungslos.
Da fällt mir überhaupt nichts mehr zu ein.
Fehler macht man. Klar, kann passieren. Kann auch wirklich passieren,
dass man, also die naheliegendste, vorsichtige Interpretation wäre,
hat halt irgendjemand das Scheißding falsch konfiguriert. Das passiert.
Und dann kann man, geht man hin und sagt, pass auf, das ist die Software,
die wir verwenden, hier kann man das sehen, die hat er richtig ausgerechnet,
hier ist der Depp, der den falschen Haken gesetzt hat, patsch, patsch, bin ich.
Und ich trete jetzt zurück, weil ich ein blöder Idiot bin und die eine Aufgabe,
die man mir anvertraut hat, nicht richtig hingekriegt habe, ich übernehme die
Verantwortung und so weiter und so fort, kann man alles machen.
Oder man sagt, nee, da kann man aus Sicherheitsgründen leider nichts zu sagen,
wir haben irgendeinen Scheiß ausgerechnet, falsche Sitzverteilung bekannt gegeben
und in diesem Fall war es sogar noch so, dass du die Sitzverteilung,
die konntest du eigentlich mit einem Bleistift und einem Stück Papier ausrechnen.
Also Wahnsinn, Wahnsinn.
Da muss man auch nochmal Props geben an wahlrecht.de.
Das ist dann vermutlich immer noch im Wesentlichen eine Person,
nämlich der Martin Finnrich, der sich dieses Thema ja wirklich schon seit Ewigkeiten annimmt.
Diese Webseite gibt es ja schon sehr lange. hat auch damals unsere ganze,
Wahlcomputer-Analyse aus den ersten Zeiten auch immer schon schön aktiv begleitet
und dem ist das halt aufgefallen und der hat es einfach mal nachgerechnet und
hat gesagt, Leute, geht nicht.
So, kriegt mal euren Schitz zusammen. Wen übrigens das Ganze interessiert,
kann ja auch nochmal einen ganz alten Podcast von mir plagen,
weil ich habe mich mal mit ihm unterhalten im CAE 128 Wahlrecht und Wahlsysteme,
wo wir Durch dieses ganze Dickicht von deutschem Wahlrecht durchgehen und Überhangmandate und alles.
Teilweise ist das jetzt auch schon outdated, weil es natürlich manches auch
überarbeitet wurde. Vielleicht sollte ich aber nochmal ein Update machen.
Aber das ist auf jeden Fall in dem Zusammenhang ganz interessant.
Okay, die Logbook-Netzpolitik-Folge, die wir damals nach der Analyse von PC-Wahl
aufgezeichnet haben, ist die LMP 228 Interessierte Bürger.
Und die Analyse von PC-Wahl, da habe ich alles verlinkt.
Das Entscheidende ist, wir fordern ja gar nichts so Irres, wir sagen einfach so, wie wäre es denn,
wenn ihr das als Open Source Software bereitstellt und die ganze Dokumentation,
damit man halt die Implementierung und die Fehler einfach nachvollziehen kann.
Also Published, Sourced, öffentlicher Lesezugang.
Dann könntest du irgendwie vor jeder Änderung dieser Software,
könntest du irgend so ein, was weiß ich, Politik,
Sozialwissenschaften, Mathematik oder was auch immer Studierende hinschicken
und sagen, hier, check das mal alles durch, verifizier das mal.
Oder könnte es drei Leuten den Auftrag geben, den Code für die Analyse zu schreiben
und gucken, ob die gleich zu gleichen Ergebnissen kommen.
Da kann man so viele, so schöne Sachen machen für diese relativ trivialen Auswertungen.
Berichte über Audits der Software müssen öffentlich sein und so weiter und so
fort. Haben wir alles gefordert, wäre sinnvoll gewesen.
Fordern wir aber auch, das fand ich jetzt auch so krass, unsere Analyse dieser Wahlsoftware war 2017.
Das ist also jetzt irgendwie sieben Jahre her. Und seitdem ist nichts passiert.
Hier hat BSI, gab irgendeinen bescheuerten BSI-Bericht, wo dann irgendwie drinsteht,
wer eine Wahl auszählt, darf nicht auf E-Mails klicken. Irgendein Quatsch, ne?
Also wirklich so an den Problemen, die wir damals diagnostiziert haben, komplett vorbei.
Und auch an den Forderungen, die wir damals aufgestellt haben.
Okay, dann gibt es noch eine letzte Meldung, ein Thema, das wir hier sehr,
damals sehr ausführlich behandelt haben.
Und zwar geht es um die Jan Böhmermann Sendung zu Jörg.
Boah, Schönbohm, Böhmermann, ich krieg es nicht hin.
Arne Schönbohm, Jan Böhmermann. Die Jan Böhmermann ZDF Sendung,
in der über Arne Schönbohm,
den BSI-Chef, berichtet wurde und ihm allerlei
Verbindungen zu russischen Ex-Geheimdienst-Unternehmen unterstellt wurden.
Die dann mit darin mündete, also nach sehr kurzer Zeit,
ich glaube er wurde zunächst sofort beurlaubt und dann wurde er an die Bundesakademie
für Verwaltungswissenschaften oder sowas verschoben, irgendein Verschiebebahnhof,
wo man Leute hinschickt.
Weil es war für Nancy Faeser in Anführungszeichen die eleganteste Methode,
weil den jetzt irgendwie aus
seinem Dienst zu werfen oder so wäre ohne weiteres nicht möglich gewesen,
brauchst du Disziplinarmaßnahmen oder Disziplinarverfahren und so,
und da hat sie einfach quasi die Dotierung des Postens an dieser Akademie hochgesetzt
und ihn im Rahmen ihrer freien Verfügbarkeit über ihn als Beamten dorthin versetzt.
Ja, man könnte sagen strafversetzt, abgestellt, weggeschoben, aber formal,
außer dass wir jetzt für diese blöde Akademie und deren Vorsitz irgendwie ein
relativ fettes Gehalt zahlen, ist quasi kein Schaden entstanden,
den jemand bemängeln könnte.
Ähm, großer Schaden ist aber natürlich entstanden für den Ruf von Arne Schönbohm
und der klagt gegen das ZDF.
Wir haben das damals behandelt und ich würde mal kurz meine damals schon vertretene
und seitdem auch nicht geänderte Meinung nochmal kurz zusammenfassen,
weil zu diesem Ergebnis auch die Richter gekommen sind.
Oder kommen werden, die haben das jetzt angedeutet, sie haben noch nicht geurteilt,
aber sie haben so ein bisschen durchblicken lassen. Übrigens,
wir sehen die Sache folgendermaßen.
Zu Last gelegt wurde dem Arne Schönbohm, dass es einen Verein gibt,
der Cybersicherheitsrat Deutschland.EV heißt oder so.
Oder Deutscher Cybersicherheitsrat, wie auch immer. Es gibt auch wirklich einen
deutschen Cybersicherheitsrat. Das ist dann auch so eine tatsächliche Institution.
Die haben aber einfach einen Verein gegründet, der genauso hieß.
Und mit diesem Verein haben sie dann irgendwie Lobby für IT-Security-Unternehmen,
Dienstleister und das Thema betrieben.
Und haben da irgendwie Deutschlandfahne und sowas drangehalten.
Also eine völlig danebene Nummer.
Und jetzt ist es aber so, das war alles bevor er als Präsident des BSI ernannt wurde.
Und vor dem Arne Schönbrunn war der Präsident des BSI ein Technokrat.
Das war der August Hanke oder so hieß der, glaube ich. Nicht,
dass ich den jetzt durcheinander bringe.
So einer im grauen Mantel, einfach so ein Mathematiker.
Sehr, wie jetzt politisch nicht, hat sich jetzt nicht politisch geäußert oder
so. Also hat sich auch nicht, ja, der hat sich halt irgendwie sehr technisch
diesen Job da, Wahrnehmung gehabt.
Und jetzt hatte man das politische Ziel,
dass das BSI wirtschaftsnah her,
anwendungsnaher wird und hat deswegen sich dann entschieden,
diesen Posten mit Arne Schönbohm zu besetzen, der mit diesem Cybersicherheitsratverein
sich im Prinzip dafür qualifiziert hatte, dieses Amt auszufüllen.
Also so daneben das war, war das der Grund, dass man den genommen hat.
Und er ist dann auch natürlich aus diesem Verein ausgetreten, hat mit dem Verein,
wahrscheinlich hat er da zu seinen alten Vereinsbuddies noch Kontakte gepflegt
oder so, aber er hatte eigentlich sämtliche offiziellen Zusammenhänge mit diesem
Verein aufgelöst, wie sich das eben gehört.
Wenn ich irgendwann Cyberminister bin, dann muss ich wahrscheinlich auch meine
Mitgliedschaft im CCC ruhen lassen oder sowas.
Und dann hat er jetzt in dieser Situation...
Er hat zu irgendeinem Jubiläum dieses Vereins nochmal eine Festrede gehalten
und die hat er gehalten in seiner Rolle als Präsident des BSI,
der also hier eine Festrede hält bei dem Jubiläum eines Vereins,
den er mitgegründet hat, glaube ich, auf jeden Fall mitgeprägt hat und ein Lobbyverein
oder ein Vernetzungsverein, den er jetzt hier auch in seiner Rolle als Präsident des BSI ehrt.
In diesem Verein kostet die Mitgliedschaft ein paar tausend Euro und der Verein
wirbt hauptsächlich damit, dass man einen exklusiven Zugang zur Vernetzung bekommt.
Mit anderen Worten, dieser Verein ist hauptsächlich so ein Business-Casper-Verein,
wo dann irgendwie die Sales-Leute oder die CEOs versuchen, Connections zu machen.
So kann man sagen, ist gut, kann man sagen, ist schlecht, aber so ist das eben.
Und entsprechend kommt man natürlich mit diesem Namen dieses Vereins und mit
dem Logo dieses Vereins, kommen natürlich sehr viele Unternehmen,
wenigstens davon seriös, die dann auf ihrer Webseite natürlich stehen haben
wollen, wir sind Mitglied im Cyber-Sicherheitsrat.
Klingt gut.
Also das war im Prinzip, so ist dieser Verein ganz einfach erklärt.
Und da kommt natürlich jede Sau an und weil er ein paar tausend Euro kostet
und dieser Verein ja das Geschäftsmodell von den Leuten ist,
die da sitzen, kommt da natürlich auch jede Sau rein.
Unter anderem irgendein Unternehmen,
wo den Eignern irgendwie von der Böhmermann-Sendung unterstellt wurde,
sie hätten alte KGB-Verknüpfungen.
Die wären beim KGB gewesen oder was auch immer. Also ein, das mag auch sogar
alles stimmen, mag alles sein, kann aber auch vielleicht nicht sein, ist mir völlig egal.
Jetzt kommt also irgendeine zweifelhafte Firma, wird Mitglied in einem Verein,
in dem Arne Schönmum seit vielen Jahren nicht mehr Mitglied ist.
Und bei diesem Verein hält er eine Rede zum Jubiläum. Und daraus hat Böhmermann
dann gemacht, so hier der BSI-Präsident ist korrumpiert von den Russen.
Ja.
Ja. So. Etwas ungünstig für die Story war, dass er sich sein quasi,
dass er diese Rede halten würde bei dem Jubiläum dieses Vereins.
Ist in seiner Rolle, Entschuldigung, Präsident des BSI, das hat er sich wegen
des offenkundigen Interessenkonfliktes vom BMI nochmal genehmigen lassen.
Hat er gesagt, darf ich denn in meiner Rolle als BSI-Präsident hier zu diesem
Jubiläum fahren und eine Festrede halten?
Und hat das BMI gesagt, ja sicher. So, das heißt, das Einzige,
was man ihm zur Last legen konnte, das hatte das BMI selber genehmigt.
Die konnten ihm also einfach mal gar nichts.
Und ja, dann haben sie halt diese Strafversetzung gemacht, der Typ war,
also die mediale Berichterstattung war natürlich katastrophal,
man muss Nancy Faeser zumindest eines, kann man schon ihr zugute halten,
oder muss man ihr zugestehen, der war zu dem Zeitpunkt nicht mehr haltbar.
Also du konntest, also er war jetzt wegen dieser Sendung, war es nicht mehr
möglich, dass er dieses Amt ausüben könnte.
Ich glaube, das kann man schon klar so sagen.
Weiß nicht, also ich meine.
Es hätte natürlich sein können, dass die Nancy Faeser das Ding untersuchen lässt,
zwei Wochen später vor die Presse tritt und sagt, der hat keinen Fehler gemacht.
Genau.
Aber das hat sie nicht getan. Sondern sie hat ihn halt, ja, abserviert.
Jetzt lassen also die Richter in diesem Verfahren, was der Arne Schönbaum jetzt
gegen das ZDF anstrengt, sagen die Richter so ein bisschen, Tja,
wäre doch wirklich klug, wenn ihr euch einfach so außergerichtlich einigen würdet.
Wir sagen schon mal ungefähr, wie wir das sehen, falls hier jemand Interesse
hat, ein Urteil zu vermeiden.
Das ist, so wie ich das bisher verstanden habe,
in juristischen, also in privatrechtlichen Auseinandersetzungen durchaus gerne
mal so der Fall, dass die Gerichte durchblicken lassen.
Ich könnte mir vorstellen, Folgendes
zu urteilen und ich könnte mir aber vorstellen, dass ihr vielleicht…,
Also wenn ich als Gericht jetzt schon mal so grob zeige, wie das aussieht,
wenn ich urteile, dass vielleicht eure Motivation steigt, euch einfach so zu einigen.
Und da sagen die, hat das Gericht jetzt gesagt, die Parteien mögen sich doch
einvernehmlich einigen, etwa mit einer Stellungnahme des ZDF.
Und das wurde aber dann, und Sie sehen das also so, das ZDF sagt,
naja, wir haben ja niemals gesagt, dass der Schönbomben Kontakte zu ausländischen
Nachrichtendiensten habe.
Aber das war natürlich die Interpretation, die da die ganze Zeit rausgekommen ist.
Und das Gericht sagt, naja, das ist aber schon, also es mag sein,
dass ihr das nie gesagt habt, aber das ist der Eindruck nach der Sendung,
der einfach bei allen entstanden ist.
Und auch im ZDF selber wurden Berichte der Gestalt geschrieben und weil das ZDF auch sagt,
die Cybersicherheit Deutschlands sei durch Schönenbogen in Gefahr,
sagt das ZDF, das ist aber eine zulässige Meinungsäußerung.
Das sieht das Gericht ein bisschen anders und sagen,
ein Teil der beanstandeten Aussagen aus der Sendung könnte man in einer nicht
fernliegenden Deutung so verstehen, dass Schönbrunn Kontakte zu Geheimdiensten habe.
Eine Tatsachenbehauptung, die in dessen Amt klar herabwürdigend gewesen sei,
spricht also einiges dafür, dass Schönbrunn einen Unterlassungsanspruch hat.
Und gleichzeitig sagen sie aber, gehen nicht unbedingt davon aus,
dass er jetzt auf seine 100.000 Euro Schadensersatz unbedingt einen Anspruch hat.
Aber immerhin muss man sagen, bei aller Kritik, die ich eben,
also gerade dieser Verein und so, allein die Gründung dieses Vereins hat den
Schönbuben in meiner Wahrnehmung halt vollkommen disqualifiziert.
Aber man muss eben anerkennen, dass in den Augen derjenigen,
die ihn damals dahingesetzt haben, ihn dafür qualifiziert hat,
muss man einfach festhalten, diesem Mann ist großes Unrecht geschehen. Durch eine.
Durch diese Jan Böhmermann-Sendung ausgelöst. So, und bin mal gespannt.
Natürlich kann ich mir vorstellen, dass die Böhmermann-Redaktion da irgendwie
sitzt und sagt, ne, wieso, wir haben ja hier nur berichtet, alles,
was wir berichtet haben, ist wahr.
Und außerdem ist das eine geile Kerbe im Gürtel,
dass hier der Leiter einer sehr reichweitenstarken und vielgesehenen Bundesbehörde
durch uns abgesägt wurde.
Und da sind wir uns keiner Fehler bewusst, ist natürlich für die Böhmermann-Sendung
auch ein hohes Risiko, mit dieser Nummer jetzt mal einen auf die Fresse zu kriegen.
Das, bin ich mal sehr gespannt, wie das weitergeht, aber ich habe es damals
sofort in der Sendung gesagt,
dass ich nicht glaube, dass das in Ordnung war, was da passiert ist mit diesem
Mann und sieht so ein bisschen danach aus, das Gericht lässt also jetzt auch
durchblicken, dass es tatsächlich nach Prüfung der Sachlage so ist,
aber finde ich schon auch krass halt über, das ist jetzt über zwei Jahre her.
Ich frage mich, was eigentlich der wünschenswertere Outcome in diesem Moment ist.
Also ob es nicht vielleicht sinnvoller wäre, das wirklich auf ein Gerichtsurteil ankommen zu lassen.
Auf der anderen Seite müsste ja quasi das ZDF hier selber klein beigeben und
in einer Form einen Schaden selber formulieren.
Keine Ahnung, ich meine sich einigen heißt ja auf was, also auf Schadensersatz
einigen oder auf ein Statement?
Also es geht dem also in dieser Berichterstattung,
naja, vielleicht ein Statement, wäre natürlich so eine Sache,
ich meine, also ich kann mir vorstellen gut, der, also Einkommenseinbußen hat
der Schönbohm ja nicht, dafür hat Nancy Feser ja sorgen müssen,
der hat jetzt sehr viel weniger zu tun, der ist halt auf so einem Abstellgleis,
der hatte, vorher hatte der, weiß nicht ein paar hundert Mitarbeiter, jetzt hat der,
irgendwie so eine Vielzahl von zehn oder so, das ist eine komplett komplett egale Behörde.
Es wird schwer für ihn zu argumentieren, dass er jetzt irgendwie finanzielle Einbußen gehabt hätte.
Aber der Ruf, den er hat, sondern sozusagen auch den Beruf, den er noch bekommen
könnte, der ihm ja dadurch auch verbaut wurde.
Also das kann man schon so argumentieren, finde ich. Wie das Gericht das dann
aber letzten Endes bewerten würde, das finde ich, ehrlich gesagt,
in dem Zusammenhang schon mal ganz interessant.
Weißt du, es gibt, ja das stimmt, Ich bin ja auch eigentlich ein strenger Verfechter
der Maßgabe, dass Humor und Satire sich nie entschuldigen.
Man erklärt sich nicht, man entschuldigt sich nicht.
Aber diese ganzen Böhmermann-Sendungen sowieso sind sehr häufig sehr ad hominem.
Ja, das heißt da, also da wird sehr viel weniger Inhalt transportiert,
weil, vielleicht weil man vermutet, diesen Inhalt dem Publikum nicht zumuten zu können,
ja, weil man vielleicht ein dümmeres Publikum hat als, was weiß ich,
Daily Show oder John Oliver oder alle Vorbilder, die für Boomer Mann vielleicht
irgendwann mal als Inspiration gegolten haben könnten.
Aber...
Also weder für diese Hessenthaler Sache noch für diese Schönbohm-Sache hörst
du aus dieser Redaktion irgendwie auch nur ein Wort des Bedauerns oder ein Wort
des Schuldanerkennens oder Sonstigem.
Und da muss man sich halt immer fragen, ob man nicht irgendwie vielleicht auch
mal die Frage stellen sollte, ob man,
ja, wie man mit solchen Dingen umgeht, wenn man wenn dann einfach mal klar steht,
so ja hast halt, bist halt übers Ziel hinausgeschossen.
Ja übers Ziel hinausgeschossen, beziehungsweise das Ziel auch eigentlich nicht erreicht,
Unterhaltungscharakter einer Sendung zu verbinden mit so einem höheren journalistischen
Anspruch, den sie halt jetzt damit machen.
Und genau der Gedanke, eigentlich nimmst du ja mehr Schaden für deine Sendung,
wenn du nicht mal hingehst und sagst, okay, pass auf, hier haben wir Scheiße gebaut.
Das heißt, eigentlich schadest du dir mehr dadurch, dass du das nicht machst.
Insofern tut Ihnen das Gericht jetzt wahrscheinlich auch einen gefallen,
auch wenn es schade ist, dass es soweit überhaupt erst hat kommen müssen.
Weil da hätte man ja auch selber drauf kommen können. So wird diese Debatte
natürlich noch lange anhalten und immer wieder hervorgezogen werden.
Ja, ja. Alles nicht so einfach.
Ja, bin ich auf jeden Fall mal sehr gespannt, wie sich das weiterentwickelt.
Gut, dann würde ich sagen, haben wir 5-0-1.
Keine,
Linus 501 Witze.
Ich könnte sagen, die Sendung sitzt so gut wie in den Jeans.
Man sieht den Arsch ganz gut, doch.
Sehr knackig. Eine knackige Sendung.
Nächste Sendung sprechen wir dann über Sicherheitspaket und Chatkontrolle,
das wird bestimmt auch super.
Richtig geil. Leute, ja, Entschuldigung für die längeren Pausen,
die wir jetzt zwischendurch gehabt haben.
Wir kommen hoffentlich jetzt bald wieder besser in den Takt,
aber das war jetzt so eine eine Kaskade von Ereignissen, die zusammen mit der
Sendung, dem Sommer und so weiter und ein paar anderen Sachen noch ja,
ist ein bisschen ruppig geworden.
Aber machen wir jetzt auf jeden Fall. Wir haben schon ein paar Termine im Kalender, das wird was.
Wenn ihr tolle Locations habt für uns, wo wir auf jeden Fall mal auftreten sollten
oder könnten, dann schreibt uns das einfach, lmp.metaebene.me und dann gucken wir mal.
Keine Versprechung, aber wir sind auf jeden Fall sensibilisiert für das Thema. Sagen wir es mal so.
Abschließend würde ich noch ganz schnell danken, weil ich wirklich von vielen
Leuten Nachricht bekommen habe, die Blutspenden waren.
Vorher schon gab es Rückmeldungen.
Ja, da gab es richtig viel. Und Reinhard Remford von Methodisch Inkorrekt hatte
das auch nochmal bei denen in der Sendung nochmal besprochen.
Dann haben die auch nochmal ganz viele Rückmeldungen bekommen.
Die hatten aber eh schon eine Folge zum Blutspenden, wo sie also quasi live
Blutspenden gegangen sind.
Die verlinke ich nochmal und dafür auf jeden Fall vielen herzlichen Dank an
alle, die das gemacht haben oder auch in die Welt getragen haben.
Ich bin auch so froh, dass es Leute gibt, die das überhaupt können.
Also es ist einfach der Gedanke macht mich ja,
mit dem Blut ist nichts mit dem. Sorry, aber da falle ich echt raus.
Gut, Leute, das war's. Bis bald.
Ciao, ciao.